greetings from podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by blue apron let me
tell you some blue apron delivers the
farm fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everybody blue
apron achieves this by supporting a more
sustainable food system and by setting
the highest standards for ingredients
and building a community of home chefs
now blue apron offers three plans
therefore a two-person meal plan a
family meal plan and they offer a
tremendous wine plan I'll tell you what
I'm gonna do do me a favor go check out
this week's menu right what we're gonna
do is this you're gonna get three free
meals three free free ones three Monday
Tuesday Wednesday you need for free on
uncle Joey cuz you're gonna go to blue
apron calm slash Joey that's right
that's blue a peeping tom slash Julie
give you the first three meals [ __ ]
gratis on the house blue apron a better
way to cook also I'm going without it
you understand me you lift them wait
you're jumping up and down you're doing
marathons people are pulling over they
got diarrhea you know why cuz they don't
use on its [ __ ] products they didn't
have the immune Tech that stops the ship
from coming out of the ass the shroom
tech sport
they didn't have the Mexican chocolate
protein powder if you're gonna run
marathons and jump up and down and do
all that type of [ __ ] you gotta take
care yourself and that's where honor
comes in right now going on at that time
right now in press in church BAM and get
ten percent your first all it delivered
right to your [ __ ] crib who's better
than that you could start a whole new
life today with honor taking care
yourself with the Alpha brainy 100%
money back guarantee so good on it calm
right now press in church and there you
have it
you're gonna free [ __ ] 10% off
deliver the house kick this [ __ ] mule
Lee is how big this [ __ ] album I do
I [ __ ] love freshman year college oh
I got my hair out like getting better
are you 44 45 ok yes cuz that was I was
in my 30s when this came out Allison
change sound god [ __ ] Badmotorfinger
do you remember the remember the album's
singles the movie Singles soundtrack
singles [ __ ] amazing
I had a paper route if hey 40 bucks it
was every every Thursday you had to do
it for like two hours we got 40 bucks
Sean Simenson passed it down to me it
was like really a coveted thing all it
took like 4:00 in the morning
Thursday morning you pick up fill my
jello with papers and I listen to [ __ ]
the single soundtrack and you do one
hour you drink coffee for one hour and
then you smoke weed for the second hour
and then you just get back into your bed
and just pass the phone you know me and
rogue in all the liberal papers for real
yeah
Rogan delivered papers too I was a great
king I used to love that I delivered
newspapers door the door Rogan used to
load the truck up and then drop the
papers off to the people who delivered
in hand-to-hand combat yeah then you did
the same thing Thrifty Nickel that was
the name of the nickel yeah I think
Rogan did v I did the to dispatch oh you
had a afternoon paper oh yeah yeah
that's my least favorite part about
working at a CVS because in the mornings
me if you open they have to put the
papers together especially on Sundays
you have to put the [ __ ] thing inside
the periodical inside there whatever I
would just roll him the [ __ ] away oh I
was trying to get skinny so I was just
like you lift up the pay at the stack of
papers and you hold him like you're
doing your biceps and then walk up the
steps walk back down the steps walk out
oh you get [ __ ] insane I took the
route that was not in my neighborhood
which only an idiot does yeah like only
an idiot piece of paper that's not in
his paper because once you get mugged
right the neighborhood kids know you're
not from the label and they try to chase
you [ __ ] they try to intercept the
shipment it's worse than a drug bit
business it was like being my clothes
when I was [ __ ] 10 delivering papers
it was like being nycos I swear to god
because they dropped the paper off on
the bottom of five corners believe it or
not there's a place in my home town
that's got five or six corners six it's
impossible to believe it's a bagel shop
a bank a thrifty store another [ __ ]
in refrigeration store and another
corner over here five corners yeah it's
fine life as a matter of fact I robbed
the bank in there one
it was a drive-through who we know we're
kids but we used that I used to get
irate but drop there so I'd get off from
school and run there just a show to hope
nobody stole my papers and would deliver
them themselves Oh
because kids in my neighborhood will
hustle is Jackie you don't show up for
papers they steal them go up to Kennedy
Boulevard when people get off the bus
they sound for it for 15 cents apiece
what do you get for a paper quarter you
mean 15 cents yeah and you don't lose
nothing you know it's like you pay the
nickel for them it's all profit so those
kids who are hostile is I grew up around
hustlers that if you didn't [ __ ] bend
over and pick it up somebody else will
that expression pick it up and put it in
your pocket or somebody else well that
was written in my [ __ ] neighborhood
and the other one was if you want to
shoot somebody you want to kill somebody
invite him over for dinner
that was big in my neighborhood I'll
kill somebody invite them over for
dinner yeah carmine Bolzano did you find
the guy always shot him and it's his
word against yours you never saying
whatever the [ __ ] you want and you could
kick him starving put a [ __ ] floor
number it's your word against theirs he
used to always say that we were kids he
those kids always remember you want to
kill somebody invite him over for dinner
and we just look at him and go what is
he talking about
and sure enough we're all growing up and
one day we go to eat lunch and a friend
of mine goes you see the paper front
cover of the paper
carmine bounce a hand on shoots guy in
the back seven times his self defense
right in his living room
ha hysterical I didn't have that growing
up yeah we had it Ernie hair for his
shot got shot by his wife he was the car
dealer in Tampa my dad was his his
lawyer and his her word against his and
she he was dead and up but I think
something happened where she went into
the safe to get money and the gun was in
the safe and he came after and she just
pulled the gun out and shot him god damn
I remember that kind of remember like
that was yesterday I got away with it
yeah she's got away with it Mary you
were gonna shoot some money invite him
over for dinner that's why I tell that's
why it was great to live in Colorado
cause you got to make my day law or you
gotta do stuff something I got a holla
bill in Bert's window go get it and they
come put the hands up in the window and
I'm sitting there with a gun boom yup
they got four fingers [ __ ] it that's why
I love it I love for somebody to come to
my house
I what's the law what's the law in LA
though I'll shoot you and drag you in my
[ __ ] house that's what they said be
gunning that's what they said in in
Florida if you got some on your front
yard yeah that's well known fee is I see
somebody in my neighborhood I don't like
close to my house he's getting shot and
drug into my house yeah and I already
got things hidden outside then I got the
ring I'll break the ring and put
something in this [ __ ] hand and there
you go it's my word against his that's
yeah that's the way you gotta handle I
got four enables in the Puerto Ricans
they're on board they have three that I
got two neighbors to the cops and the
other neighbors Slash's aunt and I
talked to every [ __ ] with that really
yeah so we're good to go
you come to my house looking for
problems you're gonna leave they're a
limping [ __ ] I pay that much I
think about that I think about someone I
just got guns I got it yeah oh no I got
a row you just sit there wait dude I
have a joke I have a joke about it in my
Actimel
there's no better feeling than drinking
with your gun the mill the night oh my
just waiting preciate to go to help 2:00
in the morning with the Glock on your
lap just going come on [ __ ]
make sure that [ __ ] don't law by mistake
I don't put bullets in my gun when the
Joey Diaz book and movie comes out I
know that I know that directors and
producers are gonna go that scene is not
gonna go in it well I spent the weekend
in Miami with a guy that I grew up with
like I grew up with this guy he was
friends with my mother and my stepfather
and he was well known the community but
as I was growing up there was always a
rule that bro don't let him eat your
house at night I didn't understand what
the rumor was I was too young to
understand yeah and there was mornings
that I would wake up in my house like to
go to school and he was at my house
drinking with my mom and my stepdad and
20 other people and he'd be [ __ ] up
he'd be giving me money and [ __ ] and his
I would go sideways so they called the
moon gecko that was his nickname yeah I
know what that word is yeah oh yeah when
Yakko means like like like a figure like
a doll like a figurine like a moon echo
like the clown yeah like so they called
the moon echo and and then I would like
after school I would go mom what the
[ __ ] was that this morning
she's my [ __ ] moon echo you can't get
rid of that [ __ ] even though I
love moon yeah call me
everybody loved moon yet though when
yeah that was a great guy he had two
kids no I know he did something kinky
for a living
I always knew as a kid that he wasn't on
the up-and-up as whatever then I did
something for him until this day I came
home what it was because he took me
shopping I did something for him like
his wife came looking for him and I lied
I did something that was right in their
eyes that was wrong yeah he lives eyes
and my mother was like you did a good
thing he wants to take you shopping so
him and his son took me to Macy's and I
bought my Hot Wheels like a track and
three cars I don't forget my mom going
this is what you bought you [ __ ]
idiot and she took the hot wheel and
whipped me with it she goes he had an
envelope full of hundred dollar bills to
buy you like a car and you bought like a
hot wheels and a set of [ __ ] track
you [ __ ] dummy gain your [ __ ] room
you can't be anybody mama
and I felt like such an idiot because he
took all this [ __ ] but anyway the guy
was a great guy yeah you know I saw him
as I was growing up a couple times and
people gonna stay away from him when
he's party so once my mother died I
didn't see him one night having a
[ __ ] Cuban joint I'm 48 jamming Cuban
food and some guy comes and goes you
didn't or his son Michael yeah those
people looking for you and it was one
yet oh and he gave me his number he goes
he's in Miami so I call him when you
coop he flew me down in Miami and he
[ __ ] told me the story he goes uh he
goes I need a big favor from me I don't
know what's the favor and he started
crying and he goes my eldest son Julio
got killed by this [ __ ] junkie and if
I kill her they're gonna know it's me
you gotta help me with this and I'm like
so when my mother died I thought I'd
moved in with the Bender's but they call
them the policia yeah everybody thought
mr. bender was a cop it was Bobby that
was a cop yeah but the other people
thought that mr. bender was a gangster
so the other Cubans were saved you
living with the Mafia so when when yakin
would ask about me they would say he's
living with the Mafia so that's why he
flew me the
because he goes you can talk to your
friends to kill this [ __ ] from me I
would give him $50,000 and I'm like whoa
and at that point I'm like I'll kill
this [ __ ] myself for 50,000 I don't
even [ __ ] Oprah I was crazy I was
today I was 19 years old I was ready I
was 84 so he lived them like off Miami
and he gonna spend the weekend with me
make some calls see what you could do
this is why they didn't like hangin out
with him because whenever he would get
coked up he would lose his mind he was
one of the first guys to start getting
paranoid have you ever seen somebody
paranoid on cocaine oh yeah
it is the most amazing thing in the
world when you're sitting in a room with
somebody who is watching the same thing
you're watching and they will not stop
looking at the blinds or they will not
start looking at the bottom of the door
to see if there's a Sun coming through
the door yeah
so I didn't know so that Friday night he
went we went to his house his wife was
there I grew up around there's one son
was there and then he just sleep in the
back room but his sons like oh no I'm
like one of us
so the [ __ ] the dad comes back that I
got an hour away and I'm watching TV and
the dad comes back there with a
margarine tub filled with water remember
the old margarine tubs in the 80 yes
yeah yeah film yes water with a little
dish with cocaine floating on it okay
because in his mind if the cops came in
he would take the dish although the
coconut water and so now listen to me he
comes back there and as soon as he comes
back there he starts sliding down things
you know Miami yeah they have the slide
down [ __ ] windows like this just
kisses a hurricane there's so much this
guy's gonna [ __ ] me in the ass
he was this tub of coke and he's gonna
[ __ ] me in the ass this is why they kept
saying don't hang out with me yet go
when he gets coked up and this is after
he asked you to kill somebody
this is yeah like this whole like the
now after you ask me to [ __ ] if I
could go to the Mafia and get this girl
killed but doc more coke he did the
creepier he got not sexually
he just got creepier and more pass
so the last thing he did was he put
boxer underwear on and he had a 38 and
he put the 38 he mangled it a 38 and he
would have chanclas on those Cuban
chunky will lives being like chichi and
he would just walk around like paranoid
like and look from window to window even
though the blinds were metal and they
were shut over the windows here he kept
looking at him and the [ __ ] gun kept
falling out of his underwear hitting the
floor I'm like oh no oh no and Bert
after the third time the gun Whittle and
he shot his foot by this time it's 7:00
the morning he's bleeding and he's not
even like like I would have been on the
floor like a [ __ ] ah ah ah he's like
don't worry about don't worry about his
wife and his daughter his son hear the
gun go off they run back then they're
like oh no he did it again I go should I
call the and I was like he's gonna be
fine this is like every month the doctor
came it was the eighth time he shot
himself in the [ __ ] foot he had no
foot let I kept looking at it one foot
and I kept seen like little holes until
he stepped on something on the swim from
Cuba something like that that's what I'm
scared of that a gun [ __ ] goes off my
mistake that's what I've always been
scared of do that happened at the end of
the island in Tampa we were about to get
into a fight with Robinson the school
Robinson one of my buddies I won't say
his name to these that he's a teacher at
NYU but uh let's just call him Allen he
he had a little gun in his this is the
same guy pulled a knife on a guy one
time in a parking lot is a big this
black guy got to a fight at a Rite Aid
or it was called Eckerd's back then
I mean Allen had a butterfly knife you
know the ones wait yeah yeah he swung it
open that the guy like this and the guy
goes oh you're gonna [ __ ] stab me
let's do this and Allen was uh he was a
rich kid he was like just but he had a
gun in his waistband
right at the end of the island and that
you see the Robinson kids coming out and
they pull out and they all get out of
the car
and one of my buddies I think my buddy
Sal goes Allen you strapped and he's
like you know it and hit his thing and
the gun went off and shot down his leg
ricocheted off
pebbles shot out after everyone everyone
in Robinson got in took off they were
scared of us we were more scared of us
because Alan just shot through his pants
he had like white pants on bullet hole
out of his pants
Plaxico Burress style and it [ __ ]
Helen got rid of that gun that day we
were 17 years old that's crazy
such crazy [ __ ] and he didn't shoot
himself he just shot just shot right
through his pants just shot right
through his pants and then we had a
bunch of fights with those Robinson guys
but that was like when Robertson was a
family know Robertson was a school it
was predominantly I think predominately
black at the time now it's not and it
wasn't for a period of time it's just a
way you know the cities change like
demographically but I think at the time
was predominantly black and so was
Hillsborough where the two schools
Dwight Gooden went to Hillsborough
Darryl Strawberry uh what his cousin who
played for the Marlins and played for
the Dodgers he went to Hillsborough
Hillsborough had a gang called twt
together we thump and now they're you
did not [ __ ] with Hillsborough
Hillsborough was like [ __ ] scary but
Robinson was in our they were like yeah
there's a little South Tampa and we had
it we had two crew we had two gangs that
gangs that's really I'm really
overstating it one was a gang they were
called the cavemen and there was like
all it was all preppy white boys I was
not a part of the caveman and then my
school had this it was more like a club
on campus but we would fight together
and we call epu the pluribus unum you
know you know your gang is not tough
when it's named after the thing on the
penny at blur bassoon or Monty together
were one or whatever something but yeah
yeah I remember I remember fights I
remember not being afraid of fights now
looking fights I'm terrified of them but
I remember in high school just being
like fight let's do it
grab a golf club [ __ ] grab a baseball
bat my buddy we choked got hit in the
head with a steel pipe one night now I
look at it and go what a [ __ ] lunatic
would swing a steel pipe at someone's
head but back then you just like [ __ ]
happens you know it's like I think
that's why I'm most afraid of young kids
let people go but people that are racist
I go nah more ageist
like I don't want young kids around me
young kids terrify me cuz they don't
have they don't feel like there's any
repercussions in life all your dirt you
that was horrific happen when you were
young you know when you just figured Oh
life will never end and then you get
older and you're like I would love five
more years you know for like a like I
started looking at it going like [ __ ]
where did it all go like did I really
just drink from [ __ ] aids 20 or 20 to
45 you know I don't remember anything
it's I look at it proning cut because I
look at it when I was 20 and 21 I had
nothing to lose nothing to lose I
kidnapped Belen I was told all that
crazy [ __ ] yeah there was nothing lose
and if you were my friend Bert I go Bert
just stay in the car cuz you got a
family let me do this because if I get
busted I don't got a family
yeah just sent me ten bucks a month you
know saying don't be a douche bag yeah
you know I could carry you you know
thing so I always took those type of
chances but I also remember having my
eyes on a couple dudes that were older
that I thought I was gonna take down and
within two years of my thought both of
those guys did something that I'm very
happy that at this age and now at 55
I welcome somebody I make a mistake
around me I would welcome it because I'm
so experienced now I see the move coming
I see the steps I hear the footsteps I
know the walk I know the talk I know how
they show up so now I react completely
differently I react for an RA yellow cuz
one of my 55 yes life sentence now it's
ten [ __ ] years home for Joey and they
gonna put me in a [ __ ] hospital cuz I
got sleep at me you know saying we got
money for a good attorney we'll go fund
me a good attorney go [ __ ] you're gonna
go find me a good [ __ ] Jew Flyman
right there is real don't take no [ __ ]
easy nobody and they'll get me up in
Lompoc up there with the horses riding
the horses right off for San Francisco
you can visit me on the way that all my
buddies are visit me you know saying cuz
I'm in Lompoc playing tennis with DeNiro
play in that movie they robbed every
Bernie Madoff already made office in
Lompoc like all the people all the main
players if you got dooring me you end up
at Lompoc you could stab 20 nuns and if
you got money and if you can order right
attorneys they put your love box
we'd end up the right review we did we
did a we did a shoot we did shoot for
Travel Channel I think in Utah it was in
Utah it's where the the corona arches we
can you google where the corona arches
her the corona arch we did this shoot
and it's you you get hooked up
underneath it and then it's hard to
explain is that where is that grant
country to Grant County Utah yeah so
they the Crone arch is is like this big
like McDonald's arts kind of thing but
out of stone and you they have ropes my
anchor it into one side and then they
drag the ropes up under it and you
harness into that rope and you dive out
under the arch and you swing under the
arch out far it's [ __ ] insane like
it's one of the craziest things I've
ever done in my life when I want to do
it the guy said I was like I should put
on a helmet he goes you don't want one
if something goes wrong just die you
don't want to be out here suffering and
I was like for real he goes if nothing's
gonna happen but trust me if it does
just go out that's the end of it trust
me
so we did it we shoot it it's [ __ ]
amazing and then right when it goes to
air they call us and they go your shoot
was illegal if you air it there's
possible prison time for the executive
producers I'm one of the executive
producers and this guy's Paul's one of
the executive producers but it's such a
badass shot I mean it's such a badass
shot that I feel like we'll just go
viral that I that me and Paul literally
said all right let's pro and con out a
year in prison like like a federal
prison right we'll get healthy yeah
right they never put us in prison you
know they pay a little fine yeah you pay
a fine I go you're gonna go sing for the
black boys club take your shirt off and
go sing a song yeah you know we are the
world or whatever Woodleigh that's it
it's so we didn't ever we didn't have a
we never got a permit to shoot it it's
so funny how they scare Americans like
the other day what's gonna happen to
Conner in court nothing
who's Conor Conor McGregor nothing yeah
nothing is he going to court three
misdemeanors in a family buy you can pay
that's easy
that's an easy one that's it that's an
easy day for uncle
Joey that's uh take care of the family
what's a misdemeanor the civil courts
what's gonna get them right cuz they're
gonna of those files will sue well no
they can't sue because they both took
fights like [ __ ] are you serious
Rehberg has a baby who's [ __ ] up well
they got a GoFundMe page to pay for the
baby and then he got sued but he took
another fight if that was me sitting in
that thing I'm walking around like Ray
Charles do you understand me I got
glasses on touching walls
I'm grabbing chichi and town like I
don't know she's a man or I'm sorry to
grab you but no he's actually harassing
I'm blind what are you talking about
wait so they both can't sue now cuz they
took fight to fight so if you sue you
through minimal eight thousand six
thousand Michael cares it took a fight
now you get minimal I would have put eye
patches on dog I would have heard radio
waves from the glass in my eyes I would
have been a [ __ ] nightmare [ __ ]
kid I know that the feds could take
voices off glasses right that's how you
know that football thing you ever seen
when you get thrown a football and they
have those microphones on the edge or in
the eighties and nineties the feds we
could be having a conversation in here
and if they knew that we had a high-tech
surveillance equipment what they could
do is put a [ __ ] thing to the window
and they could hear our conversation
bounce off the windows you do know that
no you do know that that the feds are
that high-tech and all that type of [ __ ]
that's what they were doing in the
nineties once the Mafia started getting
boxes to sweep once people started
getting sweepers because the problem
with sweepers is like if I go please
call the sweeper they hear you so when
the sweeper comes they're watching from
across the street when the sweeper comes
they turn the bug off so there's no
micro-macro whatever the [ __ ] there's no
magnetic [ __ ] cz's
I'm no electrician genius then when the
sweeper walks out the feds are watching
you in a binocular they turn the thing
back on so in the nineties only we got
with this conversation that's how they
would listen to you we're turning around
Connor was very [ __ ] drugs
so that's what I'm saying then I would
have taken that glass from that bus and
said I'm hearing voices from gaudí
talking on the [ __ ] bus it's a New
York bus I heard the Mafia talking in my
eyeballs I would have sued to the end
then
eight settlements there there's eight
paychecks there if I'm Michael Kaiser or
Rayburn are you kidding me oh I can't
pull my hand I'm hearing voices every
time I see glass I get flashbacks losses
I'm walking around like Rose McGowan
give them same just PTSD DUP to the
[ __ ] guilt and every damn make
another million because every day I'm
going to eight different specialists in
Beverly Hills yeah that three four
hundred a pop you understand me I don't
give a [ __ ] Mike credit gets ruined
if I can't pay them there so Connors
gonna ditch out pretty easy in this
pretty easy because they gave me out the
UFC gave those guys fights right away I
paid them good money gave chiesa the
other guys fight so they can't sue the
UFC the your see ain't stupid they gave
them good fights right off the bat me I
wouldn't have taken those fights I can't
see I can't see I couldn't even see the
phone and pick it up huh that's why I
haven't called you in a week
well growing up in New York you must
have grown up around rich people who
could pay off I saw all the time did
piss you off
not at all that's a part of doing
business that's a part of doing business
when I went to Disneyland last week I
saw people who cut in line with [ __ ]
things and they pay 500 an hour yeah
next time I'll suck to read Knicks
instead of one next time suck three
dicks and you could take your kid and
don't have to wait on line four seventy
five [ __ ] minutes I've always
believed in that like I never
LeAnn's always that like oh we're not
getting the Fast Pass when you go to
work I'll go get the Fast Pass that
makes it so you can ride the ride
immediately and you're not waiting in
line and she's like oh it's just a waste
of money oh it's not a waste of money
and even the Fast Pass you can't
guarantee me I'm still sitting there
like a [ __ ] Bob Marley patience on a
monument but that's the way life is you
know I'm saying you don't want to you
want to get on the plane early get a
first-class [ __ ] ticket that's it I
just had this conversation this weekend
with the guys I was on tour with I was
like I can't it makes better business
sense for me now I have to worry about
everything know that if the flights
cancelled I'm definitely on the next
flight because if they don't have it in
first-class they definitely got on a
coach and I'm getting the first chance
like it just makes more sense and there
were
where it didn't make more sense but now
I'm like Baba Kia always for I I don't
think I could fly
coach back middle of the claim I upgrade
90% of the time yeah I just know the
cities I'm not gonna upgrade them oh
yeah I go in New York you're never gonna
ever get another crazy I've gotten a
business over Nashville you won't get
upgrades yeah I've gotten a great
American yeah oh wow every time I've
flown in Nashville I never got the
upgrade yeah and if not they put you in
the rows to the back with the more leg
space which I show you guys small other
people's parts burps and [ __ ] what
not was just burped only as you said
that but yeah I would have never [ __ ]
him taking those flights if I was those
guys yeah I would have sued the guard I
would the Brooklyn place I would assume
the security people the UFC I would have
sued Rogan for not being there in the
bus I would a suit everybody would I got
a letter on Monday everybody woulda got
a letter on Monday oh yeah even just to
send a letter for people to say no
because I might send 500 somebody might
go BAM yeah I am paying 50 grand to shut
him up but they both [ __ ] up the UFC
called him and blew smoke up their ass
and they accepted the fights nany can't
sue now they can't get no big money try
that [ __ ] sucks that sucks
I wouldn't want I wouldn't and I
wouldn't like if I if I was ray Bogle
the other guy would fake it not to put
come on McGregor out of money but he's
got a hundred million dollars he could
pay 40 of that yeah and still stay with
16 is still fighting and [ __ ] I'm not
looking to put Conor McGregor in jail
that's not what I'm saying
make them pay I bet there's a part of it
with those guys whether they're such men
meaning like they're such alphas or
they're like nah I'm good I'm not the
guy that Sue's you know what I mean
like I wonder if like those those guys
like we'll deal with it in the ring type
guys you know what pearl I was one of
those guys too yeah and now you have to
in this day and age if the wheels are
turning around you bet your ass they're
gonna super crashing oh yeah you bet
they're asking that's true Bert
Kreischer you know you know John breath
on oh what's that guy's name that plays
The Punisher oh yeah
oh great guy yeah he's from my walking
dead right he's a little be able to
podcast next month in August these good
guys in New York shooting right now he
tells a great story but guy having a
fight one guy did something to his dog
or something he hit the guy he got sued
I found out he was an actor got sued for
big money had a lot of money from his
family and everything and working off
yeah because these people look for that
so if people gonna do it to you
people in this day and age [ __ ] forget
about it in this day and age look at the
day after school shooting all those
school shootings is shouldn't this day
and age they don't give a [ __ ] jack
those attorneys come to you at the wake
and tell you how much money you're gonna
get what you gonna get how you gonna get
it I guess it doesn't pay to be
honorable
well the thing I always get cuz I'm a
sports fan and that's a big thing you
hear all like even just people leaving
their hometown like that these guys
aren't gonna be fighting in the UFC
forever so even if they get a fight
right away like it would be better it
would make more sense for them to set
them up for life is that what you're so
like kind of what you're saying yeah
that makes sense yeah people get [ __ ]
all the time for taking money you watch
the [ __ ] thing on HBO real sports
which one the one two weeks ago about
the us the us out the us the NFL no huh
the NFL came to the conclusion that yes
concussions kill football players yes
this thing and they put out two billion
[ __ ] dollars to pay out all these
families the only problem is they ain't
paying nobody why I mean then are paying
any money [ __ ] you know who's got it
bad like the guy casting off
who by the way Justin on his [ __ ]
wife had a baby yesterday his ex-wife
rocky Balboa's ex-wife had a kid
yesterday at 50 Oh Brigitte Nielsen four
years old
Oh remember she left Rocky for [ __ ]
Marc
gasma Brigitte Nielsen I had a kid at
fifty [ __ ] floor yesterday guys
that's crazy that's crazy you wouldn't
you wouldn't do that I would be scared
for my wife the kid could have to read
[ __ ] heads
welcome to her fifth child yeah 54
[ __ ] years old had a kid yesterday
but she left rocky I think well from our
Gaston Mark Gastineau is a bad
[ __ ] he was a bad but I was like
bad [ __ ] in the NFL he was
[ __ ] up the Patriots League and he
was living life he's living life crazy
that dude well now he's got the disease
and he's going in we've all been this
that certified doctors have said yes NFL
ain't pain so you have to look at a team
weight you have to look at football now
and go Jesus Christ I can't support this
no more even though I really like it I
can't support this no more they they've
all become [ __ ] scumbags they've all
become scumbags that that was one of the
funniest things Ralphie sued
Spellbinders cuz he fell through the
stage when time [ __ ] that plan your
stage has got to be built for guys like
me I'll do their [ __ ] stand spell bar
this year spell bonbon fine this is the
east of improv when the Houston improv
first moved across the street from the
improv now yeah was Spellbinder
spellbinding this was a huge club in
Houston Texas in the 90s and that's what
a Ralphie really cut his teeth on and
the beef with Ralphie and the lady was
that he fell through the stage having
Ralphie judge us
can you open that duck is like that I'll
attorney oh my goodness an attorney
Jesus Christ the attorney was at the
show and as they will pull it Ralphie
out of the ambulance he's like here you
go play a call Vince oh [ __ ] shut those
Ralphie call the next day and think I
told them but you know I looked at the
thing and it was against code didn't
have no two-by-fours information sue but
they ever help he's like well I'm never
getting right no more and the guys like
[ __ ] it you could buy your own comedy
club that's how Ralphie supposed I don't
know how true it is
I know he fell through the stage and Sue
them really didn't either get any money
yeah he got money
so lady's name was like Kim Carnes Kim
something looking up late let's see if
we could find Spellbinders Houston Texas
it probably closed the 97 96 so Ralphie
fell through the stage has never taken
them to the hospital some lawyer came up
to him and said sue because I looked
through the floor and then in having
fire garden or whatever and Ralphie got
him for a couple grand and I asked him
years later like I found out on the sly
like I didn't find out from him he never
told me one day I asked him hey oh hey
Ralphie
I caught Kim constant looking for a job
is that the name it was closed in 2013
what was her name though Fiona see it
says Danny Martinez on this article
right no that's the that's the Kombi lat
laugh spot no no that's the last one
that's the latinum in Houston they used
to have the lamp spot in the left's time
the last stop I put the last stop with
Pete yep yeah me you Riley
Pirelli the last spot was the other one
on the outskirts of Denver on the
outskirts of Houston that was it was
where they're [ __ ] there were like
animals out there and then there was
Spellbinders which was inside the city
limits no it was outside the loop that's
why it's and so then they opened the he
improv there and then we'll see Houston
and probably had to grow they moved
across the street
but yeah years later I said to a Ralphie
I call him cars looking for a week and
she said she couldn't give me a week cuz
I was friends with you what's the
problem that's how I got him like I
didn't go right up Bert that's how I got
him I didn't go up to him and go Ralphie
did you really fall through the stage
yeah I went up talked about my Ralphie I
don't know what the [ __ ] happened
I called whatever her name was to get a
week and she said I couldn't do it
because I was friends with you what did
you do over there and he's like ha
player you know the [ __ ] stage is
[ __ ] he tried to like go around and
everywhere he could and then somebody I
think Jody was in the back of she goes
he fell through the [ __ ] stage [ __ ]
you [ __ ] no I didn't and they started
getting into an argument some [ __ ] the
thing had faulted town that's what he
kept saying they had faulted town no
faulty tile from the time he jumped to
something went right [ __ ] through the
thing oh that's what [ __ ] hilarious
so I think he's suitable I asked him
years later why he said because they did
something shitty to him they didn't pay
the hospital bill something oh really so
he said [ __ ] I sued him I got like
whatever I think he paid for that for
run away don't whatever [ __ ]
yeah yeah remember when he felt threw
the chair at my house don't bring that
up please he stopped laughing last time
I couldn't stop what happened four days
he had no recollection of it and I think
he came on and did your podcast you
talked about it no we talked about it
and he texted me he's like playing and I
thought fall through a baby house he's
been gone almost a year I said to ila in
the car today I said I would she wanted
to get fried chicken and watch TV so we
were going to get fried chicken and I
said uh she'll hear you home tonight and
I said yeah I'm home but I'm going over
to do Joey's podcast she goes what was
the name of the big guy and I go Ralphie
she goes I know I think it's Tommy I
said no you're thinking of Tommy bonds
and she was Tommy bonds and Ralphie or
two different people yeah they're two
different people
she was what's Ralphie doing and I said
he's dead Oh
and just sat there silent she's like
yeah babies didn't he I was like yeah
she's like whereas I think they're in
the hills I don't know where they live
now me neither
it's very sad yeah that bums me out
where were you last weekend we did we
did the mean Sal Vulcano Nate bargatze
and Kyle Kinane did the shape Performing
Arts Center
Chicago Theatre in the Fox Theatre in
Detroit like a three day run it was hard
man I'm not gonna lie to you I'm not
wanting someone who work at night fly in
the morning work at night fly in the
morning work at night I can go into one
place and do a weekend but that that
three day run is gonna I'm supposed to
do a bunch of them and start in January
and I don't I don't know if I got it in
me like I may need to find a workaround
like a like a tour bus or a sprinter and
just get done the show and drive that
night I don't know if I can [ __ ] fly
every day like that it kind of takes
took it out of me
it's like that I did that Australian
tour where I did Perth Melbourne Sydney
I did like five cities in Australia and
you and it was setup they kind of [ __ ]
it up so that it was set up were
supposed to be like a day into a place
fly hang out for a day perform hang out
for a day fly hang out like but uh I had
to go and do press tried to fly back and
forth from Melbourne like twice or three
times and I ended up flying and
performing every single day and I was a
[ __ ] mess like a mess so I got a I
got a figure a way to do a tour I can't
do it the way like segura just goes in
and does a show and then leaves he
doesn't say hi to anybody just leaves
goes home watch his TV gets up gets on
the earliest flight flies in takes a nap
performs gets out of there like he's out
of the venue I went out and did a
meet-and-greet with the audience he
Chicago's it was like they were like you
know there's still it's a 3,500 seater
they're still you know 700 people
waiting to say hi and the way my brain
works I know this isn't healthy and I
know this isn't popular and I know this
isn't what everyone else does but part
of me says if if I paid to go see
one of my favorite comics it would be
cool if he would take the time to come
out and try to say hi to me and so I
went out I did a meet and greet with
everyone waiting in the street they were
they were there like security guards and
barriers and cops
you just go out he's gonna circle about
gear phones and selfie ready mode let's
do selfies and people are cool and I did
I divide it maybe I don't know how many
people but I did a couple hundred few
hundred people of selfies in a really
short time but I don't know if I can do
that every [ __ ] night Thursday Friday
Saturday I enjoy doing the pictures yeah
some clubs now because we do clubs yeah
I don't want to do a theatre so the
club's invited man we talked about this
we talked about this yeah Club will tell
you Joey I'm sold out the second show
you can't go out there yeah you can't go
out there
your core is [ __ ] pandemonium it's
too slow yeah
the show will start to 11:30 do us the
favor just [ __ ] go out the second
show and that's what I do with it that
Club is nothing you can do I love to
mean I love to [ __ ] if you do the meet
and greet then you are literally doing
the meet-and-greet and then walking
right on stage the stage you don't get
any time to like sit back relax your
nose is that the people that are coming
in for the second show or come and take
pictures
oh that drives me drives me crazy so now
you can't do it you can't do it because
it was supposed to be a hundred people
but now it turned into 350 and you see
the people taking pictures and going in
and going so you took a beat I'm saying
so now you cannot do it you cannot do it
I love to work and I love doing economy
but here's the [ __ ] bottom line I'm
an older gentleman yeah and you know
what man it burns me the [ __ ] out and
I'll tell you what else I'm not a
feature no more if I was featured I
wouldn't give a [ __ ] because it really
doesn't matter yeah they're not Dennis
seeing me I don't give a [ __ ] when I was
a feature yeah I'll come out and drink
all night and I don't work every week
cuz it doesn't matter I don't have to
take pictures you only people want to
take pictures of me three losses it I
don't like the headliner but like me
that's it you're better than the
headliner we'd like to Yolo no that's
great and these are the guys on the
Coliseum they
tell them that they like me more than
shut up the [ __ ] job you know but that's
the truth so yeah
you cannot give your all and like that's
why I don't do it every week it's only
it's a lot
I look at those guys like when you hear
about like you know those Disney stars
or the Jonas Brothers or you know those
people who do the meet-and-greet who
give everything to their fans like Dane
used to I go man that's a lot of [ __ ]
that's a lot of Albert's the reason I
mean Segura is not a dick he just goes I
can't you physically cannot do it you
know I remember texting Rogan one time I
was like hit or what are you Spock I was
at the Wilbur I was like am I supposed
to a meet and greet there's 1,200 people
here yeah he was like oh you can't do a
mean greet for a theater and you can't
at the Wilbert when I did the Wilbur
last time I did one show early show
couldn't do a mean greet and there were
people upset with me like upset they
bring presents they draw drawings they
make a care basket they're like I just
wanted to say hi and then the late show
I was like I was like [ __ ] it I'll go to
the bar down the street if you want to
meet me and say hi go down to the bar I
showed up I no lie there was probably
500 people oh yeah arm to arm in a bar
and I was like maybe that was a bad idea
well she did the problem at the bar is
did I have a problem with this yeah
come each other blah but there's only
one problem soon as the first camera
comes out I'm leaving
yeah that's it that's my deal let me
check the bar well as soon as the first
camera comes out or the first stupid
[ __ ] question about the Joe Rogan
podcast episode 48 Jesus when I was on
there with Bert Kreischer and I talked
about the Martians landing in Cuba
that's when I gotta go like I gotta go I
just did two shows I don't know what I
talked about an episode 484 of Joe Rogan
no do I want to remember there's so many
people tell me about Joe Rogan he's a
great guy no no no tell the best is when
they come up to you I'm their coach Joe
to come on back and see it yeah tell
them right tomorrow morning hey I got
this for you would you take this to Joe
for me no no no god forbid I'm a [ __ ]
you know yesterday we had a conversation
like the emails that we get yeah and
like the creepy emails you get from
people demanding things like demanding
things like oh wow
you
I'm doing this thing and I want you to
give it to Joe and tell Joe that I need
this and and you're like [ __ ] Tojo
yourself first off Joe doesn't answer a
[ __ ] email and Joe doesn't respond to
an email or a [ __ ] tweet he knows
better yeah he keeps some way and
[ __ ] distance were the only [ __ ]
that talked didn't say hello
was [ __ ] like that he doesn't meet and
greets which he's great at yes really
good at me but he don't think my son
will win a meeting he he don't take no
she is very quick he's very courteous
come on let's do it awesome so mother
see how much a man excuse me that time
he talked about the tub get the [ __ ] out
of here who knows what the [ __ ] I said
that was eight years ago
yeah I want to talk about a table now
those are [ __ ] hilarious when you see
the guy go um I just have one question
about chemtrails if you talked to Eddie
about this and Joe's like buddy I'm
sorry it's over thank you so much for
the picture who's next let's go I wish I
could be more like that I guess
I have to tell him listen though not
tonight guys that knock it off my
problem with my problem with pictures my
problem with like going to hang out at a
bar and people bringing out cameras is
it's always the girl who wants the fifth
or seventh picture she wants to keep
taking pictures you're like you got one
already you got one taken bring it up
like yeah let's then they go get people
oh you recognize this guy from brothers
to conch when the guys like not really
yeah can you take a picture with my
friend you know doesn't know why do you
bring them overuse of listening for me
why are you soliciting [ __ ] pictures
oh if I see somebody sitting in a
conversation I do not bother if I see
somebody involved in a conversation my
world is done my minute to talk to him
that's how my mom raised me I don't know
how your mom raised you that when
somebody's in the conversation you have
the right to come over and tap somebody
on the shoulder and ask them to take a
picture that's completely wrong in my
world yeah the one that we won't in my
world the one that gets me because I
love going to see comedy is when I'm in
the back of a show
and when people I've had one other
comedians are onstage try to take a
picture and I it doesn't happen to me
that often so I I still like taking
pictures just because weird but
to do it in the middle of a show when
someone's gonna comics on stage they
have no [ __ ] class
no no class it's like the I never went
to Irene's room duh what's the name of
it
Rumi Kaif the Ruby cafe and there was a
guy talking while a girl was on stage
like a comic talking like about this
before I got burning my next yeah
thank you that's it yup burn it my next
it's an okay if I do the joke about the
pigeon what you say it's it okay if I do
not joke about the pigeon I really want
to try it I'm doing an HBO showcase
shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up that's
doubly on stage do you not see somebody
on stage what's with the [ __ ]
questions they drive me [ __ ] crazy
yeah well they eat well they just do
little things that you sit there and go
is this necessary there's a guy at Rumi
uh coloring or drawing the other day you
know and listen I know it's an open mic
you normally [ __ ] poetry readings I
snuck into economy yeah but after a
while I got the hint and I stopped going
they didn't want me there if you show up
with a guitar to an open mic I'm gonna
bring it over your [ __ ] head
yeah I'm saying like especially a
musician like if you if it's a comedy
open mic don't come in here with folk
music I don't want to hear your [ __ ]
folk boring music man I really don't
save it for music I don't go to music
open mics for a reason yeah as I'm
disrespecting you guys why would you
bring a guitar and want to play that the
Ruby [ __ ] cafe for when it's all
comedians trying to it's getting weirder
and [ __ ] waiter out there oh [ __ ] the
people the guys have bring the guitar on
the plane those are the best they're not
even in the [ __ ] band like why you
garden this guitar why you and then they
sit all the way in the back so that
means they gotta take a whole [ __ ]
space for that measly $233 they gotta
take the whole [ __ ] space with that
[ __ ] wooden guitar because it's a
piece of [ __ ] they can't check it it
drives me crazy when I see a guy
checking a skateboard guitar or a
surfboard I want to [ __ ] shove it up
their [ __ ] ass I flew this skateboard
once I believe it and the guy and I was
every time I seen with a skateboard I
make believe like I didn't see this game
I got on the plane and I had a
skateboard and the guy said to me uh
going to see your son I was like what
look like it before it's dad he just
goes going under the bar is it going to
see your son to get him a skateboard I
was like no it's my skateboard he was
like God you skateboard I was like hey
guys how old are you I was like 43 he
was like wow you gotta be careful man
you could really hurt yourself and I was
like wait what and then I was like and
then I looked and I was like I don't
look like I'm cool with a skateboard I
just look like I I'm taking this home
for my son you know when you see those
dad's coming home from drop-off on their
scooters like the dads kicking the
scooter home and you can say oh the kid
rode the scooter to school the dads
taking it home so that's where I stopped
now the girls you know the girls are
taking over all my skateboards really
girls good with the skateboard they are
they just are they got into it like a
couple months ago and and so they go out
in the front in the front street and
skateboard around there it's a one-way
street so they just skate around and I
like sit there of course I'm I'm a
helicopter parent I make him wear
helmets and the [ __ ] pads like I'm
like no you can't Jimmy you I get I'm
like I can't I can't imagine that my dad
didn't even know I had a skateboard and
just was like I was hitting ramps with
nothing as a kid like Joe how many
[ __ ] head injuries that I have
growing up I've had I've had probably
like legit six concussions I think just
so you know just being a kid not knowing
that explains yeah that explains his
behavior and [ __ ] skateboards
well when Tom Segura fat [ __ ] girl's
disgusting job gained so much weight
after running that [ __ ] marathon now
running a marathon was the dumbest thing
I ever did
why cuz I did it and I couldn't walk for
like a week and then I couldn't run for
like a month so for a month I didn't get
to work out for a month like I could not
use my legs I couldn't use my upper body
and I put on ten pounds that month
quickies [ __ ] and now I'm from now I've
got a nutritionist nutritionist
nutritionist nutritionist and a coach
and I'm training for a triathlon isn't
that longer than a marathon no
triathlons
much easier I think in my opinion it's a
short swim like quarter-mile half-mile
swim 1015 mile bike ride and like a
three to five mile jog or run all the
things you don't do when we get some
Tony Bennett all the things you don't
[ __ ] do you want to do now Emily I'm
starting we get some shots on my man
Matthew Humphrey Ralph
Vimal sort winnable rob dukes Edward Koz
connect off Jimmy's brother Kurt is
still well Brandon Pagano and Rhoni man
the Icehouse the 7th of July is sold out
all I got left is the 13th and 14th at
the South Pointe casino and
[ __ ] Las Vegas I'll see you
there I got nothing in July I got that
and I got I got the Utah tour I got the
Burbank Airport tour all the jewel in
July that's how I do it I got one gate I
only have one gig in July that's it now
do you know how weird that is for me
where you go I'm doing I'm hosting this
thing called Rover fest which is a big
event big festival in Cleveland and I'm
doing two shows Thursday two shows
Friday at hilarities like right before
Rovers fire in the middle of the month I
think 18th and 17th of June July that's
a good place to be you gonna sweat your
[ __ ] balls oh that's gonna be hot as
far hot as [ __ ] but the Cleveland
Indians are in town you have a good time
and you home the rest of the time of you
I'm home I go off to Pittsburgh this
weekend
I do a theater the bernam Bynum and then
and then I'm doing a live podcast the
next day and that's it and then I'm done
I'm done for three weeks straight
I do the July date and then I'm done for
another three weeks two weeks I can't
[ __ ] wait
I'm done this week I got another next
week you gonna be going to the store
nope yeah I'm going to do these thing
they call today I was like I'm doing
these thing tomorrow night and I was
like I think I'm just gonna do one gig I
got one joke I'm working on about poor
people and then I said I'm not in the
mood like I just did a month and
for pressure work yeah and I'm not in
the mood for it
I agree well you know what if I want to
do comedy I want to do it if I don't
want to do not have to go no way yeah
that's it that's the program I'm on for
the next couple weeks I gotta go to
Vegas which is just a workout so now
I'll work out two nights yeah then I
gotta go to Utah
I've been riding a little bit done -
sorry but I had to start giving it a
breather I had started doing this like
music people yeah you know what man it's
been a long time and I'd rather focus on
podcasting focus on writing focus on
different things then constantly on the
road it takes a toll on knowing I tell
these agents they got no creativity
there's no creativity there's a
thousands of dollars online and you want
me to carry my luggage to Pittsburgh I'm
not doing it guy I'm not doing it I'm
trying to get the [ __ ] off the [ __ ]
Road like I'm trying to get the [ __ ] off
the road like one week a month is fine
animal die got a kid to raise
yeah I don't want to end up like these
guys I don't want to end up like these
guys bro you want your daughter in the
play prize daughter walking around
telling people my dad no stop it your
dad didn't know the [ __ ] you're working
he was done half the [ __ ] time I'm
mad at my mom I did the same thing with
my first door this is what you committed
yeah but I don't want to do that the
second time I don't want to do it right
now yeah I want to make sure I was I
want to set I doubt a meeting the other
day with this guy
he's like what do you want to do I was
like I want to do a four-camera sitcom
and shoots of CBS Radford I can ride my
bike that's it yeah it's that ain't it
don't bother that's it that's all I
wanna do you want to do I wouldn't mind
doing I wouldn't mind genuinely wouldn't
mind if a company got invested in what I
do digitally like the podcasts and
shooting videos and like taking what I'm
doing a little bit to the next level and
putting money into it and get a studio
not a studio but you know like what
Grogan has like a much smaller scale and
doing stuff out of there every day going
there every day I could do that very
easily be very comfortable do the road
when I want to but not like and but not
be beholden to the road the way I am now
but the reason I'm holding the road now
is that's the way I write also like I
can't when I'm home I try to be a dad
first I try to
with the girls and the girls don't want
me doing spots
I don't do spots you know yeah they go
to sleep at Georgia set one time
remember the night we were gonna go for
the for Jack Junior's birthday yeah and
I was like yeah I'll meet you there
I got in the car with Georgia and I go
just dropped me off at the haha she
always be joy be there I'm gonna ride
back from jet with Joey and Georgia got
the car in school so it would be nice if
you came home with us I said okay I can
come home and I'll just get a goober
over there she was no I mean like and
you were there when we woke up I go I'm
gonna be there when you woke up wake up
she does nobody like to know you're in
bed when I go to bed that that you're
asleep there I was like oh [ __ ] a girl
that bothers you and she goes yeah it
kind of bothers me this my dad's out I
was like good hey that's my boy tells me
my wife tells me at Mercy says little
things from her from time to time these
little things yeah
and you know what I have to pay bills I
have to do what I have to do it keep the
[ __ ] lights on but I also don't want
look like I think around for you every
day
I think Richard Johnny all the time yeah
I think I'm Mitch Hedberg I think they
were on a [ __ ] comics bro that had a
way to make a living here and the age is
just ruling the road that's their
easiest viable option all I've got a
[ __ ] Road and what happens is
this I can anything else
it's Hank anything else when a girl
strips tech when the girls been working
at [ __ ] the greenhouse Juicery all
[ __ ] that making 8 bucks an hour with
tips in the jaw and she goes up to Van
Nuys and shakes a [ __ ] for an hour
makes a thousand bucks what are the
chance of that girls are the squeeze
another [ __ ] orange ever again ya know
it's very [ __ ] tough then you buy a
house now they got you in debt now you
have a kid now guess what now you've got
to go out on the road and once you have
to go on the road that's a horrible
feeling when you have to go on the road
and be funny it's that way no feeling
it's a bueno feel when you're on top and
you wanna go on the road and you're
happy you want to make them laugh and
you know that you're going home in the
morning you don't have to do this for
another week I look forward to hugging
that dude and taking pictures of people
and giving them a hundred percent of
what I got but it's like anything else
that's why baseball is such a difficult
[ __ ] sport to play all these
professional athletes dude I have
thought this so think about that that
you have to be great for a hundred and
sixty games and you can't be great for a
hundred and sixty games you cannot if I
go out 20 times a [ __ ] year at five
shows a weekend that's how many shows
somebody [ __ ] what is that that's vodka
it's 100 shows that's 100 shows I'm
gonna eat dick 88 I'm gonna I'm gonna do
a 78% yeah okay I'm gonna do 78% but
sure that's not bad
that means people gonna come talk and
see me but the more I go out the more
bad sets I'm gonna have it just makes
[ __ ] sense
you can't kill eight nights a [ __ ]
week you cannot do it you cannot be on
top of your game and like you what you
said about the marathon you're a great
athlete you got a Mickey Mantle gene you
did the whole thing you ran out 26 now
but what good was it you couldn't walk
for a mile I walked after that that's
why I'm training for the marathon what
do I tell you all the time about working
out remember when I used to go to
jujitsu on Monday and I couldn't walk
the rest of the week and then I will go
to Jitsu Monday and Tuesday and I would
do the 80 pound kettlebell and I'd walk
around like an 80 pound man cuz I
couldn't do it last week I went to
jujitsu three [ __ ] times two
conditioning classes and three
kickboxing classes I can never do that
you have to pace yourself will you look
at that bird I'm looking at Lee I was
trying to figure out what Lee was doing
with his hands I'm just doing the
cameras I was wondering how the [ __ ] you
two cameras but I know it what's this
guy's what's that [ __ ] that's
right [ __ ] that's hand quickness I've
been doing that since I was a kid I've
been doing this [ __ ] since I was a kid
all day long all day long I get these
mother
I've never been able to do that I guess
you've never seen the man who died
people have no idea when I was a kid I
used to kill flies and put them in a
stack gonna light them on fire
[ __ ] what oh yeah this is a big
Viking funeral for the Flies everyone
being lip-read right now one of my good
friends said man when you work in one
time you kill a hundred flies in an hour
and you put them in a circle and you put
the gasoline on a little [ __ ] fine oh
my god I would take their wings off this
[ __ ]
I'm definitely telling my therapist then
sometimes I would you know I do
sometimes I kill a fly and I feed it to
Lulu I take the wings off and I get my
cat Lulu Lulu come here look at this cat
this [ __ ] fly she goes bananas now we
have flies in our backyard and I never
can do that
oh I kill him I kill ten flies a day
easy really
when hand quickness [ __ ] yeah and if
they're on a wall I can just squish him
don't even see me coming I can do a wall
with I love them when they're on the
window and they get kind of goofy cousin
down the window the Sun goes in their
eyes made a kind of goofy oh my god I
light them on fire you ever light them
on fire
you think they're wings off and put a
light to them oh and hear them [ __ ]
screech no you little filthy [ __ ] watch
I'll [ __ ] kill this land land by day
he's gonna land close to Lee have you
ever seen the people who tie strings on
flies legs oh my god that one time I did
some gravy somehow you catch the fly I
don't know why you catch the fly and you
freeze it and then you it gets no it
gets like mine dizzy and then you tie a
string on its leg and you hold and you
tie it like this and they just go
there's peanut caramel flies I don't get
we're gonna get something that they care
about fine [ __ ] Peter hold on one second
Allah I spray stuff like that at the
Flies I spray like Lysol or any like
bleach hairspray hairspray would freeze
the fly would just go girl Oh have any
hairspray you light him on fire remember
the final result was lighting them on
fire what a terrifying feeling for our
cats bringing in rats lately no.4 is
eating them is eating half of them but
today she brought in a baby rat like
fresh out like there must've been a nest
and are here he brought in a baby rat
and it was still moving it was kind of
limping and so
made a little nest and put it up in the
tree for the rat to grow up so we can
only kill it later but Island Georgia
wouldn't didn't want to kill it they
were like dad we got it we should take
it to the vet and see if we can get it
back to nurse it to health and I was
like we're just gonna kill it again like
we're just gonna put a rat trap out to
kill it but so we made it [ __ ] I guess
how big of a rapper they come with the
other day this big last night
that's a baby one but it comes in with
the ones like this big tail out this
long yeah and they're still alive
they're like those ones those ones are
always dead oh thanks always that I
stepped on one the other day I was
walking through the house I stepped on
it I was like [ __ ] what was that and
I turn around I'm like mother [ __ ]
lost my [ __ ] is that why you don't have
cats outside Joey yeah Oh cats cats are
[ __ ] they are hunters i watch this
cat sit at our bird of paradise tree
just sit like this just sit watching
them like for an hour just staring and
then all of a sudden just don't bleep
grab it and just bring it inside that's
what the book cat Wars is about cat Wars
is about people getting pissed off I
cats because they kill everything but
what people are lo is that they they
even uh they even [ __ ] let him out of
Disneyland at night that's how they keep
Disneyland clean that night really
without thousands of cats and they eat
all the mice and all the garbage and all
the bugs the [ __ ] like that Camarillo
sorry but this is booked cat wars what
the people are trying to do is to
[ __ ] people that kill all cats in the
neighborhood because they kill birds
they they're the blunders in the world
cats are the ark I don't know all the
herbs you don't know the strength of a
cat and I think who was saying the story
the other day it was Damon was it was a
Damon that was telling the story in here
we shot a video and the cats were out
now Damon wasn't here well somebody was
telling a story that god damn it Joey
there you go
two for two did I call my [ __ ] beer
probably but he was telling a story that
he shot a video of my house and that
the cats were out and you can feel the
energy from the cats you come on my
house at 1:00 in the morning I won't
take a bird out with a stick I'm like a
fake bird oh you start playing with the
cats and watch what happens to your home
yeah
they'll [ __ ] go your home goes up to
a different decibel you could feel it in
the air the power of the cats especially
when you have four or five oh and
they're sitting around the circle their
alertness is so [ __ ] high because at
night they turn into [ __ ] ice cold
killers yeah at night they are killers
they're known to be [ __ ] killers so
if you're in a living room with a cat
like at night sometimes I get I'll I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on the
living room it's because there's four
cats in the room and they're sitting at
opposite ends and I'm in the middle of
that [ __ ] spectrum you can hear the
[ __ ] hunt earnest they're killers
they're savages savages that's the show
I pitched to Animal Planet about cat
wars about the book to go around really
and let people know and then we went
down to the to the place downtown and
should a flower store that that lady
that lady owns a business in LA that if
you have problems with your cats with
rats instead of using pesticides they'll
come to your business leave cats there
and food to give them and where to put
them at night and everything so you
don't have to use pesticides in your
restaurant really it's credited the
whole thing like if you have food and
you have rats in that neighborhood you
call this lady and within 30 days
because she inherited the flower market
downtown LA yeah big market than and
they didn't know how to get rid of the
rats two rats kept eating the blood
yoloz or the white roses there's
something that they eat and they
couldn't figure out how to kill the rats
and she just started putting cats down
there well have on rats have disappeared
and she goes the rats were bigger than
the [ __ ] cats at one point doing rats
or our in our backyards we have a we
have an orange tree we have a bird of
paradise and the bird of paradise we're
this this the dude who cuts our bird of
paradise another bird of paradise uh
it's a queen palm it's just being like
it looks like a big pineapple and uh
this way this guy mr. gamble was the old
black man and he one time he got up
there and he's like you man you damn
lucky I ain't scared of rats we said
yeah he goes man you got more rats in
here than I've ever seen in my life cuz
they all go into the they all go into
the orange tree grab the oranges take
him back to the bird of paradise and eat
them so we have tons of rats and then we
had we had no ever since this cat we got
this cat she just start that this cats
[ __ ] up man rats can't you plug up
that tree or something oh no you got to
get rid of the orange tree you just got
to get rid of it cuz they're squirrels
eat out is we were killing they have rat
traps but they have rat traps that you
know you can't just put out a rat traps
is gonna kill squirrels too so it was it
was tough but thankfully our [ __ ] cat
just kills rats now like two a day do
you ever see rats in the man cave no no
never I would lose my [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
keep the door shut at night but yeah I
would lose my [ __ ] it is still creeping
I had a squirrel come in the man cave
one time in the middle of a podcast came
in the and they I forget where I was
with it he's that was what some New York
guy he's like there's a [ __ ] squirrel
in here I was like oh yeah he's it cuz
the or he picked Norns have the tree nut
rolled into the man cave
I get dropped and rolled in and the
squirrel just came in grabbed to grab
the orange and started eating the guts
out of the orange in front of him and I
was I'm so used to it that I don't think
anything about it whoever it was is like
what the [ __ ] who's hey I got a goddamn
squirrel in here
but yeah I said I have a pellet gun that
I used to shoot rats with at night I
just shoot rats then you gotta do the
you gotta clean it up so I did it like
two rats and then I was like
I don't know [ __ ] pick up dead rats
in my backyard and they just they breed
like crazy they were in our attic for a
while and we had to have someone close
up our attic vents because they just
chewed holes do the what you might call
it and you'd hear them running around
the attics of Park that's a horrible
feeling oh that's when I get up and get
a hotel room yeah that said once I am in
the ceilings or in the walls
you lost me jacket and you're like [ __ ]
laying in bed going that rats gonna
crawl my mouth from ilmenite yeah do
I'll tell you the worst one we had was
we had an infestation of black widow
spiders oh that was the worst because we
we saw one day we saw one we were
getting rate we were leaving at night
and there was one crawling on the
shutter by our door and I said two more
if I go [ __ ] Black Widows price
because you know I've seen a couple on
the front patio we should google it how
can you tell oh how a glass they've got
the thing on their back it's you can
easily tell it's a black widow spider no
questions asked you tell it's a black
widow spider the red thing on their back
I think so we go and go online leaf they
say black widow spiders are nesting at
this time of year and they put these
like little they almost look like tennis
ball nesting things under things flip
over your lawn furniture and see if you
have them that way you can tell Joey we
flipped over those Adirondacks in her
front yard and there were 30 on each
chair it was just covered and I started
freaking the [ __ ] out we went we got
spray we started spraying and then we
started looking I have you know you know
that uh we used to have this thing in
our back yard it was a it's like a it's
a birdhouse but it says they're very
popular
I saw Rock City is like a birdhouse I
looked inside this thing with a [ __ ]
flashlight
I'm not [ __ ] lying to you there was
maybe thirty black widow spiders all
crawling around inside it and I started
losing my [ __ ] oh grown black widow
spiders grown black widow spiders slept
since dude I got to the point where then
I was like we had wood all on the side
and I I started looking for them and
then Liane got bit by one and so we had
Clark's pest control come out and this
guy was like bro I've never seen so many
black widow spiders in my entire life
and now to put in perspective we were
never paying attention to them and we
never once got bit by them but then
Liane once we started paying attention
Leanne got bit she put her arm through
the IV to grab something and she was
like oh son of a [ __ ] something just
bit me then she got she swole up and got
sick and but you know the answer tough
redneck she looked through it but we
have had parks past withdrawal once a
month come out and spray the living [ __ ]
out of our yard like spray everything
and now I haven't seen one I haven't
seen one in like a year two years but
yeah it was
dude I was I had a hard time sleeping at
night I used to say Lilian there's two
times in my life life before black widow
spiders and left after black widows
virus I couldn't enjoy the front yard
I couldn't I couldn't well that was a
kid I had an amputation of mice right
before my mother died in that [ __ ]
house yeah and it changed me forever
like I had never seen anything like oh
my god I'd never seen anything like that
like I had been to people's houses I saw
a mouse but to see thousands of mice in
your house no there weren't that many
mice yes there were away I would signal
in room watching TV and I'd see them
they made tunnels they were to the point
where the tunnels would go when they
built the Meadowlands yeah all those
animals moved up possum this [ __ ]
animal walking home one night had heard
I'm Steve a fellow's house they heard
this [ __ ] thing jump and I looked and
it was a possum the size of a human it
was like a little girl ruined it open
from a tree he was older with those both
hands
yeah I [ __ ] ran old like a [ __ ]
fact because I never saw a possum that
big in my life but I saw its Jersey
there's possums everywhere I told Rogan
this he didn't believe me when I was a
kid opossums and rats would come in
people's toilets and what they do is the
cops come to the house and they put a
netting in between the toilet seat and
the back and they pop the thing up and
they shoot the rat or the possum right
in your toilet New York City broke
really rats come into the [ __ ] toilet
system know you're [ __ ] and there's
a rat in your [ __ ] toilet oh [ __ ] can
you imagine that shock that sure next
time you talk to [ __ ] you're gonna ruin
I gonna be able to sit comfortably do
you ever go to talk to Opie yeah
Opie and Jimmy you know yeah yes time
you talked to Jim Norton Opie Opie was
telling me a story then in New York
there's so many rats now that they're
not even waiting for the Sun to come up
before they go out now that now they go
out looking for food when the sun's out
so your kids playing at the park and
there's rats all over the [ __ ] heart
looking for food that's how bad that is
I cannot deal with I can't even look at
a mouse I saw a mouse with you was it
with you I saw a mouse the other day
with somebody in the car I was in the
car with somebody and we were by Bank of
America over on Laurel Canyon chase
chase right back there yeah and I went
back there to pee is something I saw a
[ __ ] Mouse I almost died I never see
a mouse out on the street everyone's so
easy a big [ __ ] black rat right by
the office here oh do we had it we had
our thing in Florida were cockroaches oh
my god how you just took the words out
of my mouth to cockroaches I remember
when I when people they brought
cockroaches we'll listen I tell the
truth I tell the truth ok that's one
thing I'd say things about people but I
also include myself when I [ __ ] up
nobody had roaches to the Puerto Ricans
of Cubans came that's a [ __ ] I did the
[ __ ] of research and that's the truth
cockroaches owes us you've been conturo
to throw those things that are like this
those [ __ ] cockroaches that come from
Cuba they open up and they say why they
imply dog I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says those are Cuban cockroaches
Alfred I claim responsibility that's
what happens that's why the Cubans
killed
that's why they killed Kennedy who those
things bothered me so much they are
disgusting
just to look at and when you step on all
they crunch
don't like the people who have hissing
cockroaches for pets
oh yeah asker hissing cockroach is it
the thing oh listen to him
you don't know he's a whatever the [ __ ]
they always do died when I was in one
hole Oh [ __ ] boilers down with water
we love a man
time with them when I was in like it's
kindergarten or first grade I was laying
in bed and I was looking at the ceiling
and I couldn't figure out what was
moving on the ceiling and all of a
sudden it drops and lands on my chest
and it's a [ __ ] two inch cockroach on
my chest and I lost my [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I couldn't sleep my bed alone for
another year I was in a store I was
eating sushi in New York as a grownup at
like 25 years old and we're eating sushi
and I keep feeling this someone throwing
[ __ ] in my hair and I'm turning around
and there's this group laughing like
behind me so you do it once I'm like
what the [ __ ] they do it the second time
and I turn around it happens a third
time I go hey are you just throwing [ __ ]
at me and they're like no I go what the
[ __ ] you laughing at and they're like
it's a cockroach it's flying into your
hair and it was [ __ ] falling in my
hair and flying out it like three
different times and I went oh I got up
walked out I was like oh my god I want
to throw up dude [ __ ] roaches or the
that is that in Florida there would be
infestations of contrast and and in New
York - listen I saw a [ __ ] oh I had
to be six maybe five this is how much it
sunk into my [ __ ] psyche I saw a
[ __ ] my godmother used to have a wolf
I used to call him and lowball this
beast dog his [ __ ] eyes would shine
he was evil and he would hunt the rats
in the basement I mean big New York
rights in the 60s I'm talking [ __ ]
rats with heads but one night I went
back to the title wolf up near Raul Raul
wasn't my god he wasn't my godfather he
was married to my godmother I'll never
forget this we made a turn and I swallow
a roach
that had to be the size of a small Mouse
you know well I'm stuck out in my head
was his eyes he wasn't no [ __ ] water
bug I'll tell you that I know the
difference me knows me I'm cockroaches
and a regular [ __ ] road the Cuban
cockroach will fly at you you know don't
go like right in your face right in your
face dog you'll [ __ ] your [ __ ] and
we'll use the tentacles the way the
tentacles move or the legs when you step
on them and when your cat eats them if
you can't eat some the one leg sticks
out of their [ __ ] mouth he won't like
that it's [ __ ] crazy that [ __ ] and I
know for a fact it was Cubans and Puerto
Ricans brought those roaches I'm not
accusing nobody I'm not saying nothing
there's certain nationalities that
brought certain creatures to this you
gonna [ __ ] in Miami they got everything
between the Brazilians to [ __ ] hear
all that South American they brought
every [ __ ] spider dude every [ __ ]
snake boa boa always run and I'm not
Rams than anybody and your luggage
college boys college boys are the reason
that bought that pythons are all over
Florida and myself included my buddy
Chris Carter bought a Python a ball
python and put it in a cage and then the
middle of the year it was just gone it
was gone and we were like him and your
Python got out and he was like oh [ __ ]
and then we realized we're living with a
Python in our house that there's a
Python floating around our house and
then we don't know where it is hey
what's this thing it was probably this
big probably maybe my feet that's let's
say four feet won't be the tops but
don't they grow no yeah they grow but
they don't go really fast ball pythons
aren't that they don't get that big but
it's enough to [ __ ] in it's enough to
scare the living [ __ ] out of you so he
has a ball python it gets out we were
afraid or were afraid for like a week
and we forget about it and the only time
he brings it up again is the day we're
moving out where you're in college you
have like loads of laundry you just grab
an armful to laundry put him in garbage
bags and he just comes in and I have a
closet filled with honor he goes if you
see my ball python remember to grab it
for me like hold on to it don't kill it
no one oh my god now I'm reaching into
bowls a lot in bags of laundry just
going like what if I feel a [ __ ]
snake in the like
it was the scariest moving process I've
ever had in my [ __ ] life but we never
saw it and now they have pythons all
through the Everglades they're their
pythons in backyards attacking children
in Florida like pythons run rampant in
Florida and that is frat boys right
there that is frat boys and [ __ ]
rednecks rednecks they just didn't want
their Python and just like I'm done with
it put in the backyard let it go but
yeah I had a guantes never let them go I
had nothing I had a dog growing up like
normal [ __ ] people yeah I didn't have
no hamsters I didn't want nothing
nothing I have no love for nothing then
I finally went my mom died those people
have a cat and that's how I started
liking cats no really he used to bring
home everything yeah everything birds
animals I'm gonna forget being coked up
one morning and not being able to sleep
and being like laying on the bed and
frisky was his name yeah like a white he
climbed up on me and the window was open
with the screen and it was like a
bluebird I'm gonna forget him like he
would make that noise with his mouth
that noise is [ __ ] amazing he was
gonna go frisky go gather and [ __ ] you
two hours later
frisky would have that bird the [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] amazing that cats can do
that well he was bringing home skunks he
was bringing home [ __ ] squirrels that
cat was tougher than nails he has he was
missing his leg was missing he got the
fights with [ __ ] everything yeah and
everybody had a dog in my neighborhood
Jimmy Bowser had him Jim Bowser Allen
was a gay dude I love him to death but
he had a dog growing up he wasn't gay
when he was a kid I know he was gay he
was [ __ ] chicks two at a time when he
was a young kid cuz they all thought he
was good-looking yeah he was like George
Michael he was hiding the secret so
still can't believe George Michael with
I watched that show it was [ __ ] great
the autopsy of George Michael and the
[ __ ] final hours and Venus only he
wasn't [ __ ] at the end when I moved here
they caught like I moved here when Iowa
was on fire like I moved here on a
Monday and that Friday was
Hollywood shootout sharp I was that on
our way up to get a job with Doug
Stanhope scar I borrowed Doug Stanhope
scar you know about the North Hollywood
shootout yeah at the bank Oh father was
right up the street from us right up the
street from us and then also that week
the following week was with George
Michael got caught in the bathroom
because listen to me guys I was living
in the trailer with Carol in a park in
Beverly Hills and when we left that park
like three days later he got caught
Church I'm off in the park with a Kaley
in that same part the party looked at
the part being Carol lived that in the
[ __ ] trailer that's [ __ ] great you
know I wasn't here yet I was still in
what I don't think I was still in with
you here in York no that was in the
neighborhood where we go mm right and
what was it like you were what you
wanted this neighborhood that where were
you up into her were you like in high
school zone and it was [ __ ] up that
day but it was [ __ ] [ __ ] great
that's crazy that changed the game is
that what did we did they have less
strict rules on assault rifles and in
California at the time you know I don't
know what it was I know you couldn't get
out of the 101 and like I couldn't get
on and I had to make like I backed off
the ramp you know where I would tried to
get her on I tried to get on the 101 by
the 101 cafe Yeah right there Gower it's
not our exes or whatever it's called and
it wouldn't let me get on the ramp real
so I worth up to Claudia I went around
and I went through 101 Dinah to eat
breakfast and when I got to the 101
neither they're like North Hollywood
shootout I'm like I'm going off
Hollywood to apply for a job they like
no you're not yeah 101 is closed I was
headed to North Hollywood to apply for a
telemarketing generally that was that I
remember when that happened were seen
the footage of that and then reading I
read an article about it just recently
there was a great article was that yeah
yeah just about a month ago a great
article came out about what they wore
how that really changed the game that
change with cops use and I changed that
was [ __ ] up Dave well you guys here
for like a huge earthquake
there haven't been a big there hasn't
been a big one since four I don't think
what 94 I have now I've only been I've
only experienced one earthquake that I
can acknowledge maybe two but like one
where I was like well it wasn't an
earthquake was just a tremor it was just
a tremor where you went whoa oh wow
that's crazy
nothing big nothing massive my wife
there was one like probably now like
three years ago I'm guessing there was a
morning one it was like 6 a.m. and my
wife was outside walking the dogs
outside with a girl with the dogs she
said was pretty amazing to be outside
during an earthquake because the ground
just kind of moves under your feet and
the trees all just leave shake like Shh
she was like it was really crazier than
your car alarms go off but I haven't
really experienced one oh you will keep
[ __ ] around I've gone on the road so
much Joey
that scares me yeah the road one man
Olson isn't it quick and you can't live
like we change it back yeah I can't lay
eggs boil his clothes Burbank Airport is
closed John Wayne Airport is closed like
a big earthquake like that
Petra finds to shoot him you know all
the twenty hands got guns and food and
you're - yeah it's only need two big a
one big dog around here from our
neighbors with guns cops yeah I got the
whole thing that's that's that's why you
leave you leave in peace two rings the
back rings that we were gonna throw we
were aren't me and I got these kids they
you're like George's friend like three
of our kids friends they're all live in
the same neighborhood you've met him oh
you met him over at the house a few
times Eric and and Darren you met a nice
people we were gonna throw a an
emergency party right but the theory is
let's see how fast we can react to an
emergency so like one weekend just out
of nowhere like on a Sunday we just text
each other
attention emergency party there's been
an earthquake get over to our house with
supplies now and you bring over like
like what would you what would you bring
in an emergency and see how fast you can
react to this because I think everyone
thinks they're ready but no-one's
[ __ ] ready no one's ready I got a lot
of immune ition I got a lot of
ammunition that's the only thing I just
bought a ridiculous amount of bullets
for the guns cuz I just thought the
shotguns way too heavy I don't [ __ ]
know what I'm doing the goddamn shotgun
I'm just gonna be redoing to drywall in
my house but I got a bunch of hollow
points you went nuts the nuts Joey I
didn't want that many weapons in my
house I didn't want them leave because
I'm crazy yeah I don't want that much in
my house I bury [ __ ] oh I got a lot of
[ __ ] buried
I have jeez I have a Taser I have a
Taser like the gun that shoots it I have
like five cars refill cartridges I've
got a stun gun I've got these
flashlights that are bats I've got so
much [ __ ] in my house and the one time a
homeless guy tried to break into our
house I couldn't get any effect could
get to any it's just I just Brazil it
was the only thing that stopped it
Priscilla was the best at that dog is
the best purchase I made because
everyone's terrified of that it's all
Friday you see for sure you done yeah
that's a good that's a good but there's
[ __ ] not a poison your dog oh
yeah my dad take some [ __ ] bread with
some [ __ ] paint thinner and your dog
is sleeping for an hour you know I'm
saying [ __ ] I was crazy like that crazy
like that [ __ ] but I would never hurt a
dog and there's people well I have
something everywhere I'm always prepared
there's always a knife there's something
I tell my wife where they are so she
don't put a hand back there I'll touch
him out on that mercy go back there wait
what are you doing that before your kids
I've always been from my stepfather I've
always learned to be prepared yeah I got
some men at the store I always have
something somewhere just a nice just in
case at that time I had to be from La
Jolla I went down there I didn't come
get me and I got all the pool balls and
I'm strategic the pool ball all over the
[ __ ] place plus tool in my pocket you
ever gonna hit the head with a pool ball
I know it's not a good feeling it's not
a good feeling I find it's like getting
hit with a baseball without the
stitching you know I'm saying
I felt that so yeah I have [ __ ] stress
stacked everywhere so something happens
there's always something
gota know if I'd meet you at Starbucks
does it Lisbon a knife this the 6:00
a.m. I put a knife there at 6 o'clock I
know exactly where I'm gonna sit I know
the reaction time I know the whole
[ __ ] deal yeah you have to do that
when you're a [ __ ] creepy person like
me LM saying you have to be on top of
that [ __ ] I learnt that from my
stepfather I learned all that [ __ ] from
him like just yeah you have to assume
the other searcher yeah so if they
search eat or have nothing on you but
you still got to piece it in the flower
plant then I got a [ __ ] though I used
to hide [ __ ] all over eet too yeah
that's the place you could definitely
keep pieces everywhere there's so many
products only potted plants and
everything just get you're out in the
open man I know that usually as soon as
you say that I go you are out in the
open
I'm on the oh whatever you're on the
open you have to have something I have a
hanger in the car I'm always I remember
you telling me of that never some Peter
man with a coat hanger at night they
don't see it they don't see a [ __ ]
thing this what I'm saying when I was
younger like there was this guy I was -
there was two guys I was thinking of
Robbie well I'll never forget there was
a guy that I had even the cops watching
him to help me Rob this guy like I went
to a cop buddy of mine like I gotta
listen we're gonna Rob he's gonna cut
Jay love him give me all the info on
these I'm collab Leigh and I'll never
forget that cop koala me one they're not
calling me come and get me at 3:00 in
the morning Lord you're lucky and then
jumped that dude bro he's just some guy
went to jump him he took the gun or
things I shot both guys that guy is no
joke I was like whoo and then I went to
rob this bookie one time and he was the
other crazy [ __ ] that I thought
that thank God cuz in a year where he
shot two people something he did
something crazy so all these people that
I thought were older and they were a
little weak yeah don't [ __ ] with those
guys they got it down they've been
through it yeah they know the [ __ ]
deal when we got the guns I told the
girls I was like obviously you guys
don't ever touch my guns and Georgia
Cortina Georgia Tech not had never in
the islands like worst case scenario
then I'll grab one I was like weasel
quick
okay this is going with me I was like
she was like worst-case scenario then
I'll grab one I was like that's not
what's wait what's worst-case scenario
whew she was like if I come home and
people are tied up and think you guys
are all tied up and I'm free then
obviously want me to break into the
house and go around and grab the gun so
I'm like no that's not the last thing I
want you to [ __ ] what [ __ ] movie have
you been watching really when I mean I I
guess no I guess because my theory is
they're just gonna take the gun out of
her hand and she use it and shoot her
and then she shoot us yeah she is a
young and that's Jo you know what to do
yeah god I I'm just cuz my when I move
down here I have like a kit with some
clothes and like a a water bottle and
some batteries but I don't have anything
to protect myself it's I never thought
about it you should all get a gun No why
not ah it's good to have an apocalypse I
I guess but I also don't think I really
want to live through the apocalypse to
be honest oh come on I don't think I'd
do well wait oh but you already set up
to succeed no I'm not I'm the slowest
one
no you've got all that fat you can just
live off that you don't have to go get
food no that'll be good for the what if
I survive but if they fight if there's
any believing this building I'm gonna
I'm gonna go downhill do you have any
plans for natural disaster uh earthquake
just kind of leave you just getting on
the road I wanted to get I wanted to get
like a dirt bike to you so that I could
get my family out yeah right in the
middle of the interstate so what if the
roads are all messed up see that jump it
on my dirt bike
I got a shotgun in the SPAC sleeve I got
a I can see what your honour comes up
with this movie you look at you have
like a hold the rock movie going on
that's so [ __ ] funny oh look at this
flower right here lady ready
let's see you ready oh I got it oh my
god you didn't get with your phone holy
[ __ ] no it's all my [ __ ] phone that
Joey just does it with his hands like
he's like mr. Miyagi or something I did
I've never maybe these huh maybe it's
because these flies are all flying into
these bongs and they're a high [ __ ] and
they're just like my reactant
I'm off I don't know what Joey's smoking
it's probably it's dragging them in here
he always says my next month like hummus
but I don't your neck smells like hummus
yeah I don't need a hummus before I come
here because he will say it so where's
the thing that you're touching to switch
the cameras with my keyboard oh oh my
god I'm such a [ __ ] idiot
I've been watching you do that with the
keyboard I'm like what are you inside
you some people think I'm having like a
tremor or something they think I'm
having like a seizure
I'm just sweet are you high right now a
little yeah I'm like a 5 yeah don't tell
that to Joey no yeah well they he's
going through all those squirts so do
what I mean you fly a lot yeah do you
ever get nervous about going through and
I'm finding something or yeah I won't
fly with anything nothing I'm afraid to
I went to the I went on a cruise and I
brought this pen with me right and I was
terrified and they stopped me and
they're like we have to go through your
bag you have some stuff in here that
you're not allowed to bring on the
cruise ship and I was like I was with
the girls I was like oh my god they're
gonna find weed but I had little bottles
of vodka I didn't know it was a you know
it's just a plain bag and so I was
terrified bringing this through and then
I only used it once so I was like what's
the point of me bringing it through I'm
trying to not smoke weed because uh I'm
legit I'm training for this triathlon
and I can feel it my lungs immediately
we don't like to that I know don't the
Diaz brothers do triathlons
yeah but they do legit triathlons I'm
doing a sprint triathlon they do like
legit like two and a half mile swim
[ __ ] 20 mile run okay they so that's
what I thought earlier when I was saying
yeah I thought I thought the triathlon
was part of the marathon no no no you
know the Ironman is harder than the
marathon they have they have Ironman
sprints or they have Ironman serious
Ironman and then there's have regular
sprint triathlons I'm just doing a
sprint triathlon it's which is still
really [ __ ] hard but it's not it's
very doable I think it specially if I
train that's what I'm only doing it so
that I'll train I'm only training so
I'll lose wakes I feel fat as [ __ ] right
now so when do you start with the
nutritionist I started last week and I
was doing great and then I went on the
road this weekend and though [ __ ]
wheels came off I didn't train and run
and do anything I eat like [ __ ]
I hate pizza the middle of night is
Chicago my [ __ ] Coney dogs and
Detroit and then she's coming over to my
house tomorrow she texts with me she I
everything I I everything I eat I
register on my phone as she can see well
then she'll text me and kind of keep up
with me she she is the nutritionist for
the New York Mets and for the Yankees so
she's like a legit nutrition list and
then and then my coach just kind of
sends me like training things and my
goal in training is to do two of the
events every day so like I get on my
spin bike and I just pedal not really
hard you're not like killing myself but
it still does kill you pedal for like 45
minutes
you know like 30 minutes and then get on
the treadmill and run for 30 minutes or
20 but that's not that's what Rogan told
you I'm telling you why are you doing it
that's not what's that training on the
elliptical no no no no you got a run on
the street or on a [ __ ] ship my
treadmill my treadmill is the Air
Assault runner I don't give a [ __ ] if
it's to Air Assault [ __ ] it's harder
it's harder than running on the road
it's your the treadmills not powered you
power it by your own feet so it is a
[ __ ] beat is the most uncomfortable
treadmill you've ever been on your life
if you run on that then you go on the
run on the road the road feels so much
easier so that's why I do that and then
I'll do that every other day I'll do the
two and then I'll do like a hike from my
house up to Fryman up to the top of
Fryman and then hike back and we'll you
riding this bike at cuz that's the claws
of danger right there that's what you
gotta get the helmet that's where it
gets but it gets really dangerous on a
[ __ ] ball yeah so you can't really
got to ride the bike up prime with him
but yeah drive the car with the bike in
the [ __ ] car in order to find 12
miles to ride a bike you got to go into
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere Chandler
bike path I think it's like 16 miles
yeah nobody and their bikes bats no you
have a cross [ __ ] every Road off
Laurel Canyon no no no no that's Det
there's too many stupid [ __ ] people
yeah dude
you have to assume when you're on a
bicycle that the guy that is just - and
I see it I see it all the [ __ ] time I
see it all the [ __ ] time there's two
people I know that person got hit by
[ __ ] bicycles cars after I
told are you [ __ ] crazy a girl that
hangs out with my wife I still put a
helmet on one night after yoga go where
you going
alright my back home I'm eco friendly
listen don't do it haha I wish a guy
opened the door she broke all her teeth
surgery on her lip the home you can't
find your bike on the streets you can't
ride your bike the streets I ride you my
cousin jeigh broke her elbow industry
it's terrifying
that's why a lot of people go up to
Malibu but even still those cars are
flying there I know that's that's the
nightmare you have to go to North
Hollywood Park go to know Ho Park
yeah that track youth a ride your bike
around yeah she take your mountain
biking you just ride around there for
[ __ ] two hours that's it and you run
around there for two hours that's a
track I'm taking my bike track taking my
bike to Alabama out where Leanne is cuz
there's just [ __ ] long stretches of
road there I'm gonna ride there I still
have to buy it I'm just right now right
now I'm running it riding on my spin
bike yeah you gotta get rid of this pin
money brother you one of those pending
you something in your pool yes I know
swimming at the Olympic pools where at I
did one up in Pacific Palisades well
that's where the best pool running wait
up to went over the Pacific Palisades
where it breaks that's the best pool
program where's the bird man Verdugo
pool and they got a swimming program
they're a Masterson program you could
beat at 7:00 in the morning nine eleven
one three six nine
Verdugo Park that's a baby right there
in Burbank Boulevard who the [ __ ] are
you kid that's the best pool in the area
and they got a pool Fox not far at all
no what we think you're dealing with
here joint bananas Pacific age no no
that's our I had to do that so we did my
cut my coach was up there coming go [ __ ]
himself
don't give me if we do go far Pacific
Palisades just go [ __ ] himself
that's an hour an hour just one an hour
back yeah I mean me okay I'm up a you
know I pay a few months over there
there's a nice pool nice white people
where I mean clean hot dogs a [ __ ]
tremendous they got a kiddie pool it's
colder than [ __ ] they're open at 11:00
but you go
leave will he went twice daily I went to
the 24-hour fitness pool house your
24-hour Fitness pool it's okay it's kind
of busy but it's not bad
I don't think as long as long as you
need it to be you just need it to be 25
meters it's uh basically Daren back
would be like a yard yeah yeah if you
maybe double I went to prison I got into
all that [ __ ] you're into it for real
before I got locked up the UPS man was
built and when they opened up my [ __ ]
mouth I was lifting weights and I was
riding the mountain bike right yeah
right at the Hertz and I hit the bag and
lift weights well I knew I was getting
locked up the question was when I wanted
to be in tip-top shape you gotta see
this [ __ ] UPS man first of all this
guy was [ __ ] every check on the run
he had six kids and he was [ __ ]
married women single women really women
were [ __ ] up kids he didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah I would watch it
I was going to college I'd be out there
washing cars and every place he walked
into he made out with the chick
it was [ __ ] hysterical good-looking
Italian dude from like Cleveland the Sun
so I asked him when that so how do you
get in shape you got [ __ ] six kids
you had six [ __ ] kids I go how do you
[ __ ] get in shape and he goes I swim
I gobble to come from with you one of
these days you know when you open your
mouth you're like I'm gonna come with
you all these days oh okay I'll meet you
there tomorrow what time you I'm gonna
meet you sexy goes yeah yeah six be
there about 5:45 a.m. and I heard am I
gonna wait on them he goes yeah I strum
this call it a sex there's two classes
six is a seven but the beginning classes
at 6:00 I'm like alright I'll be there
yeah and when he walked through I was
like what did i do what did I just do
and I can't get away from this guy I see
him every [ __ ] day it's like I'm
never gonna see you know karate schools
you walk it yeah I'll be back next week
you sign up then you never go back in
now I'll be back next week yeah yeah
I'll bring the money next week then you
never come back that's I couldn't do
that to him
so the next day I woke up at 5:30 I
drank some [ __ ] Tang those are the
old tank days Oh
Katanga licious Oh a little Tang in the
morning in the glass and I'd rode my
bicycle down in the way he was a lady
don't like kiichi she was Hawaiian
beautiful and she was Miss iron woman
1984 and 85 oh well she was a warning
and white [ __ ] beautiful three kids
she had her body was [ __ ] spotless
like quiche I mean spotless spotless
three kids and she's like I got a value
jump in the pool
and Here I am twenty five muscles you
know yeah [ __ ] it let me show this [ __ ]
when I got [ __ ] I never forgot I jumped
in the pool and I must have burnt I must
have gone for four minutes and I popped
my head up dog and I had moved maybe two
steps I've had gone sideways and she
goes okay we got another beginner and
that my heart just sunk well like I was
like oh god I thought I was a good score
and that's a why would black people when
I was a kid when I came back from cube I
got the [ __ ] patch yeah you can swim
and [ __ ] and for [ __ ] one week bird
for one week I would have to go there in
a cordless six for one week and just
hold on to the edge and kick and she
taught me how to kick correct because
there's a way the kick people don't kick
right I [ __ ] it all the time you have to
kick but there's got to be a little bend
in your knee slight bend if not you'll
[ __ ] up your knee when you swim there
has to be a slight Bend and you have to
swim a certain way she wouldn't let you
use your arms until you learn how to use
your feet just am I gonna let you use
your arms so come back so for two weeks
I used my feet then for a week she just
made me [ __ ] now put the paddle
between your legs and just pull oh yeah
Oh put the paddle between your legs and
you gotta remember that you leave you
get home you're like this week your back
is like this you're like Johnny back
people like what happened to you nothing
swimming all day you're [ __ ] yoked
yeah you get a V from doing this [ __ ]
from pulling because that's all it is
it's just pulling she taught you how to
correct
your hands have your hands come in like
this swimming it's so detail-oriented
dude it is it is so like and you think
you know what you do it that's the
problem with swimming you're like oh
I've seen people do it when you jump in
a pool or the summit coach teaches you
how to swim you leave they're like that
was [ __ ]
uh-huh that's why I had to go to the
Palisades cuz he wanted to watch me swim
he was like I need to see if you can
swim yeah and I was like I could swim he
was like no you I need to see that you
can like you know like he there's two
different types of people the people
that know how to swim and people who can
swim and luckily I mean not luckily but
just luckily I was always on the swim
team
all the way up until high school so I'm
like at least I can I can legit swim
like I can swim I could swim a
quarter-mile very easy knot and get
through it it's not gonna kill me it's
gonna win me like when I did it the
other day I was definitely breathing
hard but uh but I can do it because I
just know the proper technique and I
know to go slow and I know to when you
know that when you when you're taking
your breath you need to rest up on your
arm and make sure that that's keeping
you buoyant and uh all the little
techniques they knew how to flutter kick
and especially freestyle I'm fine with
the mice my stroke was the breaststroke
which today if I do I get [ __ ] I'm out
of it I can't do I couldn't do I
probably couldn't do a sixteenth of a
mile on it on a with a breaststroke I
could do this
yeah the breaststroke I could do that
all day long I can't do this anymore
that I can't do I can do that one super
easy and I can't do that and forget I
can't connect but er fly I could never
do butterflies I was starting to
butterfly before I got locked up
oh yeah I even did a triathlon I'd swam
and rode a bike really yeah I did it the
to the by not the air I the by him I got
my and I rode the bikes and I swam or
whatever the [ __ ] that was yeah right
before I got locked up she was great and
it was Jane I really like Jane I always
liked Jane but she was a tough [ __ ] bro
she didn't give a [ __ ] and you know what
by the time I got locked up I was
already in lane number three there was
four lanes you had to move up the lanes
really and she'll be like [ __ ]
you'll be in that lane for ten years if
you move me up to lane number three
because you have to do like it's like
jujitsu you have to do calm
petitions yeah she wants you to get
involved so first I did a couple slim
things out of Boulder reservoir and that
was scary ish oh I can open water yeah
how do I know that [ __ ] that scares the
minds and minds in Lake kiste ik yeah
what's up here yeah latest ax fine and
that I'm doing the Malibu like a month
later that's scary cuz that's open water
half a mile which means one open water
you go swim out to the ocean in Malibu
big waves done who gives a [ __ ] you're
swimming in big waves oh yeah me i
swimming pools controlled substances I
don't wanna get bit by a shark I don't
know if I starts all I'm thinking about
how to start keep it light that's all
I'm thinking about are 44 just wanna do
it for fun you know saying I was I wanna
do more I wouldn't mind lake triathlons
but then I think the real challenge is
can you do that open water ocean because
that's open water swimming so different
than then like pools were no [ __ ] no
[ __ ] Sherlock
no [ __ ] open [ __ ] war this woman is
different their pool is nothing hold on
the warm of the water they either you're
like [ __ ] John Claude when the waters
warm
yeah you're doing all these oh yeah you
gotta see yourself you're doing [ __ ]
somersaults I don't wanna try that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] when you're off the
beach bro I almost drowned when I was
[ __ ] 5 in Coney Island I got caught
one of those [ __ ] things it to me
besides one of those [ __ ] spinners
undertow undertow yeah I got caught one
of those they're quite one in Miami I
don't know how the [ __ ] I'm here I'm
scared all that [ __ ] I got utmost
respect for the ocean utmost see I
suppose I grew up surfing so I did I
never you had respect for the ocean but
you understood that your your rappers
that your connection with the ocean was
you were simply something in it you
didn't have control over it I think
people get caught caught up drowning and
I'm there's like probe servers that die
drowning so that I'm not saying that I'm
some amazing guy in the ocean but a lot
of what happens with people that get
caught up in the ocean is people that
maybe don't respect it enough and so
like I remember we got caught
a riptide surfy and you're like alright
very quickly you knew I don't swim
against that I'm just swimming with it
and to the side and getting the [ __ ] out
of it and then I'm gonna right I'm gonna
rest I'm not gonna be afraid of how far
out I am and I'm gonna paddle back I'm
gonna paddle back and I'm gonna rest I'm
gonna paddle back and I'm gonna rest but
you see some people like to get out in
the ocean and they're just like they're
like in jean shorts and they're like
gasps [ __ ] this and all of a sudden they
get caught out in a Riptide and they
start panicking and that when you panic
in the ocean who does your [ __ ] you
donger you're done I've been a lot more
scared of the ocean than I ever was
recently like these last probably five
years of my life maybe a little less but
these last five years I've been I'm
scared of the ocean more than I've ever
been
like scuba diving's freaked me out and
never freaked me out before but scuba
diving was freaking me out just the
ocean in general I just start I maybe
I've gotten to the age where I'm like I
don't know if I need this extra thing in
my life that might kill me you know but
yeah we went so I've been what surfing
in Fiji and I just part of me was like I
get thrown off the board and I'm just
like winded I'm not the kid I was I'm
like winded and I'm [ __ ] like holding
onto the board and I'm trying to get out
of the whitewater and I'm just paddling
I'm like oh [ __ ] this every time I went
surfing I went surfing in Puerto Rico
and it's probably the first time I've
been surfing in big waves since I was a
child I was I was never afraid of big
waves I was never afraid of wiping out I
was never afraid anything and as I'm
paddling out all my instincts that
happen when I was a kid of like alright
these waves were pretty big I need to
get past them the instincts of getting
past the big wave so you don't get
mauled all was very I was very cool with
and I got out pretty quickly but then
once I got out past them and I'm sitting
on my board and I'm watching waves come
in and judging where I need to be in the
end the break to not get [ __ ] up I
started realizing oh I'm not I'm not had
the ability to catch one of these but I
don't have ability to surf one of these
waves and I definitely don't have the
ability to survive wiping out on one of
these waves when ice out there Joey for
forty five [ __ ] minutes without
catching away of just sitting there
panicking going [ __ ] and some
guy came by on a jetski and I was like
I'm scared and I need to get out of here
and he was like I figured that's what
was going on
you haven't been moving and I was like
okay he was at Cuba Puerto Rican guy
said it like broken English and he just
had grabbed on till he hit a little surf
thing on the back I got to the front of
my board grabbed on a little surf thing
and he waited and he towed me through
the surf brought me in and I just got
off and I was like I'm done
look give me catch a wave I was like I'm
done I would have gotten [ __ ] killed
but yeah I don't I don't [ __ ] around
with one of those beautiful beaches I've
ever been to
with intense waves is Bondi Beach in
Australia I'm in that place those waves
are [ __ ] legit and there's not even
that big but you just there's so much
power in them you know growing up in
Florida we always had [ __ ] waves it
was like you never could get really hurt
then you come out to the Pacific Ocean
sit and and you're just like oh you can
[ __ ] die out here yeah oh [ __ ] that's
the comparison really you see it that
way the Pacific to the Atlantic I know
the resent looked at it that way
Atlantic was different the Atlantic
Ocean of my opinion was tricky in that
there was rip tides there was there was
undertow we didn't get you you get that
in the Pacific but like the Pacific is
just there's so much stronger like the
wave just is so much heavier and then I
got into it I got into a thread roars
watching at this place called Tia poo
where it's like the big world's biggest
wave just the thickest wave I don't know
how these kids [ __ ] do it I really
honestly look at them and I go that's
the thing about youth you just don't
know what you don't know what can kill
you I guess I don't [ __ ] know yeah
Malibu come to a triathlon with me not
at this age my knees is shot you know my
left knee I'm my right knee I got that
surgery done again I mean I try to stay
but there's just some [ __ ] to say that
you just yeah for me it would be I love
to drop another 30 yeah you look great
well yeah I'm down to like 270 something
that's great I gotta go down at 2:30 and
then I'm the knee surgery or maybe maybe
throw running into the
port wha I bumped back up to to 35 to 37
right after the marathon that's where
I'm floating at right now and I'm just I
just it's all on my gut my belt and it's
a lot of it's just booze we know and I'm
not working out I'm just on the road
boozing not working out the next day not
burning any calories eating trying to
eat healthy but eat like [ __ ] and I got
to lose
I got to get down below 220 I got to
lose like 1015 pounds how's your dad
though you know he just started eating
marijuana regularly why he came out he
came out like a few weeks ago for
something for my daughter's graduation
and we went to cryogenic therapy we went
to cryogenic therapy place over on on
Ventura yeah that's us crap they're
[ __ ] great they're great people and I
told him I said I said to my dad I was
like my back's hurting I'm gonna stop by
cryogenic therapy it was George's
birthday Georgia was with us George he
goes you know dad I've always wanted to
try that I saw video of you doing it I
want to try it so we go in I said hey
can I come my daughter do it they're
like how old is chefs at 14 they're like
yeah and they're like you're her
guardian and I was like yes so George
and I jumped in to do it my dad has had
harp procedures and so they could they
need a doctor for him to get in the tank
but they said you know we can do
isolated in like freezing we can just
bring you in the room to mend this your
knee my wrist dude my knee last week
they did his knee in his hip yeah and he
felt [ __ ] a menace tremendous crowd
therapy Chris they great great [ __ ]
people and and he great he got out he
was like now if I just had something
that would help me sleep and they said
the marijuana place right down the right
on the corners not that bad and my dad
was like really he goes would with that
would that help and I was like yeah it
definitely helps and it's George's
birthday and you know my dad he'll try
marijuana but he's never been like goes
buy me some marijuana so I can take it
home with me so we bought him $180 worth
of edibles got on these pretzels that
are three milligrams got in these mints
that are 2.5 heats couple pretzels those
mints yeah delicious yeah
those men too great yeah CBD mint the
breeze mints that [ __ ] great and now
he's he's every night he'll eat a
pretzel and have a glass of wine and
he's a sleep cycle all alone and then
and then on Sunday
this last Sunday my mom was home and she
goes uh your dad a the pretzel when he
woke up I said really she's like yeah he
was having anxiety and he thought a
pretzel my fix it and I go did it fix it
she was yeah but he keeps calling me
dude because you know my dad's not a big
weed guy though although they start
again I was like hey dude let's listen
to some reggae dude he's all over it he
loves it when I first went on the Weight
Watchers I got off the animals yeah
really big like I was like and I was
finding myself sleeping three nights and
then having problems to realize
frustration sweet prob
yeah frustrating like tricking nyquil
and [ __ ] you know oh because I mix it
up a little bit I don't let my body get
used to one thing I don't want it to get
used to like what's the [ __ ] in Turkey
trig enosis you don't trip the fan trip
trip on that trigger don't like your
dream tryptophane that works too later
on the joy yeah oh you mean melatonin
Bella told me that's two nights gaba
gaba that's too late
y'all have had that yeah then the other
t-that's two nights the reefer tuna you
follow me sawing then one that I'll take
a [ __ ] anxiety pill yeah which'll put
me out I'll drink a half a beer but for
I wasn't I wasn't I'm always eating an
edible
yeah all that gobble gobble and all that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] don't work it don't work
like an animal does you sleep like a
[ __ ] baby really when I eat I've
never eaten edibles to sleep oh my god
when you eat those mints work eat 200
milligrams of those mints chubby and you
will sleep like a [ __ ] baby you I
don't think I would I think I'd be up
here me sitting on the couch here and go
to sleep my baby my baby go to sleep my
baby go to sleep please Rula he Lola hee
hee hee I'm telling you I was watching
the champ yeah last night when I got
home that he just signed over the horse
to the side he just signs over the horse
at the betting parlor yeah and he
borrowed the 2000 from fade that away
and update the book he just came to the
track to take the kids horse Ricki
Schroeder's horse and he beats the [ __ ]
out of the bookmaker he beats the [ __ ]
out of it yeah and next thing you know
I'm like I gotta watch the rest cuz he's
in jail Ricky Schroder you ever see that
movie Jesus Christ what a [ __ ] you
people bet I know fuck-all hasn't seen
it he's too busy watching orange is the
new purple with [ __ ] none other Scott
shot let me tell you something when
Richie Schroder comes into that jail
cell if you're a man oh if you're a man
any type of man you will cry even if you
were transgender and you switch
governments you're a man you will cry
that's how much it affects your manhood
well he punches the wall he tells that
little kid he can't watch him don't want
to go live with that lady yeah and he
forces him he throws his own son out of
that cell and tells him to get the [ __ ]
out of here I want you no more you
little [ __ ] it is you have no idea this
is what moviemaking
was [ __ ] real not this [ __ ] they're
off
that was a great movie that movie sucked
- dude but next time I had one I was so
high man attaboy I had to turn it off my
house was like I can't believe I'm
turning off the champ took all the sleep
because I am so [ __ ] tired from this
edible yeah and I used to play with the
edible that's the problem you that when
the edible tells you to sleep you have
to go to sleep because if you don't go
to sleep when the edible tells you to go
to sleep then he [ __ ] with you then he
keeps you up which then the edible turns
on you yeah when the edible turns on you
and be put home alone what the [ __ ] are
you talking about I've been there I'm
telling you that when that animal tells
you it's look nappy NuLu time when you
catch yourself falling asleep the first
time Trinity vo because if you stay up
against that edible then it turns honey
then it wakes you up then it's like a
shot of thought to expresso you might as
well drink coffee cuz you ain't gonna
bet now
what else happens it wakes you up and it
starts making you think I'm gonna make
your mind think that's making that joke
what happened when you were in the sixth
grade when you kissed Lucy at the prom
all that dumb [ __ ] comes into your mind
now it's 5:00 in the [ __ ] morning and
you gotta be up for a plane at 8:00
that's the worst
so when the Edible tells me it's time to
go to sleep I go to sleep yeah
and that's your lesson for the day you
ain't saying perfect when that laughable
tells you it's nappy noodle time it's
nappy know the time we Kelly one of
those mints tonight then I'm in
Pittsburgh this weekend yeah this is the
same stuff breeze but this is the spray
a thousand milligrams 20 milligrams of
sprea Pittsburgh this weekend and then
and then I think I'm I think it's that's
it I think it's that you're just doing
one theater this week doing one theater
at the Bynum Friday night Friday night
and you're back Saturday yep and then
the 18th and 19th in Cleveland Houston
August 2nd 3rd and 4th that's it that's
all I need to know if not they forget
anyway yeah what are you wasting their
time well they won't know where you're
gonna be tomorrow and do [ __ ] much
I'm gonna go make a blue apron right now
are you a laborer I don't know we got
Ford we got backed ups we're gonna make
- what flavors you got - you don't know
I don't know we got we'vewe've we're big
blue apron family well that's why
tonight we're gonna talk about blue
apron you understand because they got
the two-person meal plan and you have
the family meal plan we got the family
meal plan I'm gonna be a wine mean put
meal plan this is what I'm [ __ ]
talking about people you understand me
blue apron skip the meal planning and
get straight to cooking with blue enjoy
unforgettable meals inspired by the
vibrant cooking of the Mediterranean
like seared salmon and spicy are in
salsa sent it around fruits veggies and
lean meats and plenty of olive oil you
understand me these recipes are
deliciously nutritious with incredible
ingredients and chef designed recipes
blue apron lets you see the power of
what food can do blue apron will deliver
fresh proportion ingredients and
step-by-step recipes right to your
[ __ ] door that can be cooked in
under 45 minutes the menu changes every
for every week based on what's in season
and is designed by blue aprons in-house
Ilyn every team
blue apron office 12 the recipes each
week and the customers can pick two
three of four recipes like Burke did
based on what fits their schedule let me
explain something to you let me check
out what this week's menu you got creamy
caramelized onions burgers with apple
and pickled pepper salad you've got
Kristi Tegan's garlic and soy glazed
shrimp with charred broccoli and hot
green pepper sauce are you kidding me or
what you got spicy penne pasta with
zucchini and capers and you got roasted
chicken drumsticks over cauliflower with
also feta cheese than ours are you
kidding me or what that's a meal you
understand me on top of that you learn
to cook like a family a family who cooks
together stays together if you got a
girlfriend you cook with your girlfriend
a couple that cooks together stays
together so you checked out this week's
menu what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna give
you your first three meals for free at
blue apron comp slash Joey that's blue
apron calm slash Joey get your first
three meals for free blue apron a better
way to cook number two like I told you
in the beginning everybody wants the
[ __ ] gonna happen but nobody wants to
die Bert
contact [ __ ] all bring it on at Tom
you want some [ __ ] strength and
protein cuz mine get all let's get all
this stuff get the [ __ ] calkins Barry
that's good yeah Hopkins Barry was here
last week did you talk to him no no I
farted watch I listened to the podcast
with Joe was a great podcast he's great
kid and I think I followed him on
Instagram I follow him on Twitter yeah
he's a great guy he's a great guy he's
got great supplements down there
whatever you need qalam up especially
for you triathlon that shrimp check the
shroom tech [ __ ] in the sport I'll
hit them up I'm gonna send them a tweet
go to either calm right now press it
jerk BAM and get 10% off your next first
[ __ ] on and that's it and
that's that I want to thank my brother
Bert Kreischer for stopping I want to
thank the [ __ ]
I want to thank the model of the church
key she coming in and I love you
[ __ ] I see you [ __ ]
Thursday morning Wednesday night ready
to rock all right stay black I love you
and don't forget about us kick that
[ __ ] melee